Jesus fucking Christ.
Put It on the wall.
Episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Just started.
Hey fuckers,
uh,
what did we brought to you about today?
Today we're brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com is a great resource.
If you a great service,
if you run your own business,
do you run your own business?
You know what a pain in the ass it is to go to the fucking post office with a
box of shit and have someone who doesn't really want to be their way it all out
for you and it takes a long time to wait in line.
It's a pain in the ass.
The beautiful thing about stamps.com is that you can do it all directly from
your own house.
You weigh your shit,
they give you your free digital scale.
You weigh it,
you,
you print up the stickers for the postage,
right on your home computer.
You leave them out for the post man and you're done.
It's beautiful.
If you buy any of Brian's kittycat tee shirts from death squad.tv,
that's how Brian sends him.
He sends him off from stamps.com and for him it's like the difference between it
being really easy to do and a huge fucking pain in the ass hours,
hours difference.
Next,
you just print out the whole thing at once because essentially with the desk
squad artwork and all that stuff,
you've started your own business,
you know,
and you,
you really don't have any employee.
So it's like,
yeah,
it's a lot of work and man,
you're so every time we go to these shows,
I see these fucking tee shirts everywhere.
So it makes it way easier for Brian and a,
if you go to stamps.com and click on the microphone in the upper right hand
corner,
you enter in the code word j,
r e and you get this $110 value where you get 55 bucks and postage coupons,
a free digital scale,
$5 supply kit and a four week trial.
It's a,
it's really cool service.
And uh,
like I said,
if you,
uh,
if you have your own small business,
it's awesome.
And if you don't have your own small business start when you were.
Yeah,
you worked for somebody really fucking figure it out.
He said create something.
I bet you want to.
If you do,
you should do it.
And if you do it,
use stamps.com.
Use The code word j r e and save yourself some cash song.
Do you ever check the mail anymore?
Like what's,
what's,
what's your frequency for checking the mail?
Uh,
you know,
if I had to get something delivered,
you know that's it,
right?
Yeah.
I mean like letters and shit.
Like what are you doing?
How many emails too?
But it's getting really bad though where I'm like,
seriously,
just ignoring my mailbox and it shouldn't do that because what if there's like
some legal shit in there?
Especially you,
you've scandal a son of a bitch.
I know and knows what kind of nonsense you've gotten yourself into.
Tell the truth,
son told the truth.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by Ting Tang is a,
a cell phone company and wasn't rogan.ting.com they use the sprint.
If you ever,
if you heard this before,
tough shit.
All right,
let me say it again.
I don't want to think I want to to fuck soon.
Soon commercials.
I'm tired of saying them bitch.
Okay.
We're both tired of this.
However I got to get through them and I'm not sure there's another way to do it
and if you're tired of hearing me talk period,
I fucking understand it.
I'm not exactly thrilled with you and myself either after all this fucking
hours.
All right.
If you're getting annoyed at me,
it's totally understandable.
I would get annoyed at me to take a break,
man.
I said a couple of weeks off the show notes.
Go,
go do something else,
man.
No podcasts for a month for you.
How about that?
If you're into the cell phone,
if you go to [inaudible] dot com forward slash.
Rogan,
that's the,
they have the HTC one asa,
which is a,
it's kind of interesting.
It has speakers in the front of it,
which,
which you know like most phones have them like underneath and stuff.
So it makes sense and actually has like a,
it looks like an old Mac book.
The design of it.
It has a very,
very good sound supposedly.
Yeah,
but who the fuck place speakerphone phones.
You know,
like unless you're showing someone a video.
Yeah.
Which I guess it's possible.
It happens like once a week.
Right.
It does look dope as fuck though.
I went to galaxy s four.
Yeah.
Well with the point about this,
um,
this website haven't really talked about is there and less sort of a small
company,
but they use the sprint backbone.
It's not really that small anymore.
But what I mean by small as it's not 18 t,
it's not Verizon,
it's not sprint.
It's not one of the big ones.
But they use sprint service.
So you get the same service he would get if you were on sprint.
But you also have the advantage of not having any contracts.
You also have the advantage of the way they have the pricing structured.
It's really sweet.
If you don't use as many minutes as you thought you would,
they credit you on your next bill and drop you down to the next level.
I mean,
what fucking company does that?
It's,
it's,
it's beautiful.
No contracts,
great phones,
great service.
Check them out.
And if you go to Rogan,
no tin.com forward slash.
Rogan is that what it is?
God,
Dad,
I should know that.
I think it's four inch slash.
Rogen.
Yeah,
ting.com forward slash blog and if you go there,
hmm.
Checkout Ting has all sorts of great URLs.
This isn't one of them.
broken.ting.com I think that might be,
it actually sounds right.
You would sink.
We do this every week.
We should know we're going to get it right.
Fucks his bloody up.
Yeah,
it's Rogan.
Not 10.
Got comp.
Sorry.
I didn't want to be so pretentious and it's put my own name in front of the
company.
It's our fuse to believe that it was structured.
So anyway,
go to [inaudible] Dot com save yourself 25 bucks.
That's rogan.ting.com and you get a $25 credit either on a new device or on
their service,
which is excellent.
It's great,
cool phones,
cool company and that's it.
And great for international.
If you traveled to different countries,
I found Brian had a party in Canada.
Yeah,
cost him $5 on his phone.
He was on sex lines.
Am I believe it's still sex lines,
man.
That's the one of the weirdest things about going on the road as you get like
local,
uh,
television commercials
and every now and then like a sex line thing will come up.
Like,
come on man.
Really?
2000 and fucking 13 you're calling strangers and jacking off.
So weird.
That seems like man,
they can't be a lot of people.
This is the fucking Internet.
Why were you paying someone to talk to you?
What demographic is dialing those roadmaps?
Maps is so much cheaper than that.
Rum,
rob maps.
That's Brian's site and go jerk off powers the best spots.
All right.
It's all Brian posting with 30 different screen name.
Hi Guys.
It's Brian closing as a bunch of people arguing with each other all about who
gives the best hand job.
And then it will create a website for it.
Like Brian in a website.
It's one of my favorite pranks of all time.
And it was a called step Pepsi Spice.
We've talked about it before.
It was,
it's literally one of my favorite pranks of all time when Pepsi was dumb enough
to buy Pepsi Spice and make that start making that stuff but not smart enough as
well to get the Url Pepsi Spice and that God.
So psycho over here gets Pepsi spice.com and starts,
starts printing this fucking blog about how he's been drinking Pepsi Spice and
his health is eroding and he's only tricky.
Pepsi space does.
Yeah.
And he's like dying.
It was really funny man.
It was really funny.
This was before you even work.
No
dirty work.
And this is where I uh,
I brought up that I was hanging out with Lindsay Lohan at one point and we were
chopping up mushrooms and snorting it and she caught him o'kane and then Doug,
Stan hope actually tried it doing that like,
like a couple of months later.
Terrible.
That's a terrible idea.
Yeah.
This is actually just only half of it.
The other half got deleted but I might have it somewhere
and coke together.
Sounds like a fucking mistake.
Yeah I have people do that shit.
Candy flipping that he would do it though.
Like with other drugs available.
It's normally when you're a little kidney like lets smoke banana peels.
What are you doing Doug?
Well I think it's probably a proven thing though.
It's probably got a very specific effect.
I mean I don't know what it is but I bet the mushroom and coke club like the
people that are really down with that shit,
they'll probably tell you you're out of your mind.
That's the way to go.
Wow.
There's not really many pro coke advocates so you know,
is it still up there?
Everything's up on Pepsi's place.com
or is it that it got to wait but there's a lot of websites talking about like
the Museum of hoaxes.com
dude,
I've got to fucking give you
those.
Outstanding.
He's one of my favorite things you've ever done.
I was hoping the story would have ended in and then Pepsi bought it from Brian
for a million.
They only did it for one year.
I actually kept it and I was planning it for the holiday season the following
year.
I was going to have it like a different version of it and uh,
they,
they didn't bring it back though.
It was discussed.
It was one of the most gross doing fucking brilliant idea.
You know what Brian,
you really should
be talking about this on stage.
That would be a really funny bit.
Really?
Yes.
Relaying the whole Pepsi Spice Story and then like breaking down all the
different shit that you said it was going to do to you too.
That was really funny stuff.
That's like perfect type of material for stand up that you've always been in
doing pranks like and then just go into it.
I took like,
it's really funny story for your new clean show and it really does taste like
dog shit.
Like utter complete total dog shit.
Yeah.
This was the commercial for the Pepsi Spicer.
Right.
I'm giving myself blow jobs and
that's a great man.
The next morning put so much effort into this.
It's so crazy.
Yeah.
You're out of your mind man.
I was really,
really funny flag.
It's kind of amazing.
Oh,
I know.
You know somebody actually Mandarin Mandarin actually sent me a cease and desist
letter.
It looked like it came from Pepsi.
That's hilarious.
Did you listen to it?
I don't remember.
I think I did for like a day,
but then I figured it out or something.
Oh that's funny.
That's fucking hilarious.
Yeah.
Uh,
last sponsor on it.
Dot Con.
If you go to o,
n n I t and use a code name rogue and you'll save 10% off any of the supplements
and a,
we don't just sell supplements.
We have a lot of shit now.
It started out,
it's really just supplements,
but what we're trying to do is become like a human performance website.
We're trying to sell you shit.
It's good for your body,
whether it's good athletically or good in terms of a supplement or a mood
enhancer or a good source of hemp protein or walnut almond cashew butter,
which is trying to sell you cool ship.
And we even have Dave Asprey's bulletproof coffee.
Yes,
carry it in a store,
bitches.
Um,
lots of cool shit.
Lots of strength and conditioning equipment,
kettlebells,
things of the like battle ropes,
weight vests,
just stuff to get you fit son.
So I use a code name,
Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements.
Boom.
Anything else Brian?
All right.
And fucking hit the music.
Let's get this bitch cracking
experience.
Powerful Tait Fletcher.
Oh Gee.
Death Squad is in the House,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Oh Gee.
And of course Mr Dave Asprey's.
Well,
Tate Fletcher is probably your biggest fan dude.
This guy,
he touts your virtues and he was the one that came into the ice house.
Uh,
when he did the podcast last,
he had this fucking gigantic beer keg sized,
the mugs my size because I figured you guys would have their setup.
I trusted these two fully lit.
He's got two canteens of it with,
I mean it's huge.
I love you take and you're so fun.
You're always always so fucking enthusiastic about shit.
You will get eaten.
You so excessive like to the brain,
like Costco buying coffee,
ice an animal.
Tate and I lived together for like four months.
Yeah,
that was fun.
I hope you learned a lot during that time.
I learned you live like a bear.
Like
Kyle's everything in his corner and they just go in there and hibernate.
The best part was the,
was the tank to go down in that.
I never really appreciated every little,
every little scratch and cut that you get grappling,
but you really do when you get in one of those things where you got to learn how
to deal with that stink.
But it's only lasts,
lasts for four or five minutes at the most and it's going somewhere else.
But man,
it's one of those things where I really wish more people knew about.
I talk about it so much that people tell me to shut the fuck up.
They're like,
we stopped talking about the tank.
He tried it.
It's like it's,
it's safe,
it's legal.
It's,
there's no worries.
It's good.
It's a great source of magnesium.
Just getting to that,
when people talk about wanting to get the benefits of yoga and stuff like that,
like you were the first one that I ever heard talk about like all those poses
leading to a place of,
of kind of like a supernatural experience with yourself and all that kind of
thing.
What yogis were originally trying to do and,
and that's a lot of discipline do that,
you know,
but like to get into to and like to have the benefits of like a massage or real
deep relaxation of all that stuff come and just getting into a tank and that's,
that's fair.
You know,
that's available.
Yeah,
you can have and you don't have to be good at anything.
You can just lay there in bed and the best part,
especially if you learn how to relax,
that's a thing.
Like I've had people tell me,
Oh,
when the Turkey during the dark,
right.
And I'm like,
God damn dude,
Dude.
Do you know how to use your brain at all?
Like how did you not,
how did,
how did it do nothing for you.
I feel like too,
if you're living in a way that you're just dawned on me the other day,
I was like,
you live kind of an aggressive life tape.
Like I've never thought that before.
It never dawned on me.
But uh,
but if you're really attacking life in a way,
like you're after stuff,
you're using your intellect,
your using your artistic side,
you're,
you're really going into things full fledged and you need a relaxation.
You need that.
If you're just kind of secondary all the time and you get a tank,
maybe I can see that.
But like if you really need that release on the other side of things,
yeah,
maybe.
I just think it's a good time for self reflection and I don't think people don't
get that enough.
People don't.
You don't get enough time where you can actually just sit and do nothing.
We try to multitask,
try to watch TV while we relaxed while we look at our Twitter while we talked to
someone who's near us and we think it's relaxing,
but there's still a lot of shit going on.
It's just a lower vibration.
When you get in a tank,
it's,
there's nothing going on,
man.
There's nothing.
There's no life anymore.
It's disconnected.
If you can just ignore,
just start learning how to stay still.
Stop moving,
ignore the fact.
Have the tank,
except the fact that it is.
I can just be just be and breathe in this state.
Here's the thing,
you guys are pretty into your bodies.
That's what I'm talking about.
Talk
to me.
I noticed,
I'm not saying that each other's bodies,
that's a different animal all together.
Talking about chuck and fuck jerking off in front of a mirror.
If you're in,
if you're in there though and you get nothing from it,
and it's probably because your brain is mostly not connected into your body.
So for a throat
it could be anxiety.
She can be tweak about shit and they can never get comfortable.
It's hard to get comfortable,
so you start thinking about a lot of stupid shit that's bugging you.
It's distracting,
you know,
managing the mind is one of the most critical things that you need to learn in
this life that learn how to manage your shit.
The first time in my life,
I couldn't remember,
like when I realized that I didn't always have to get mad when something
happened,
I could cut my shit together.
It was a beautiful feeling.
Yeah.
It's like,
and to actually pull it off,
like the pull it off when someone's being incredibly country to you and you just
never get upset.
That's beautiful feeling.
Yep.
I had the best one of those ever.
I finished this Shaman class just planning three first of all,
how dare you say I finished the Sharman class with a straight look in your city.
I spent a week learning about and stuff and,
but here's the thing,
I was in this weird state,
I got pulled over somewhere down by Joshua tree by a cop.
Right.
And I was like,
I'm doing 70 in a 65 like whatever.
They just assume everybody out there is high on meth.
Yeah.
Pretty much comes out with this guy.
We better check calmness about me.
This guy,
you know,
normal attitude and all of a sudden he just like,
like does something and cause,
oh.
Uh,
and he starts completing the car and then when he's done,
he writes me for like five over or whatever and says,
you're a really nice man and shakes my hand.
Wow.
I've never had a cop.
I mean even pulled over like,
I don't know,
50 times,
I tend to get tickets,
but this guy,
you could tell he didn't even know what to do with themselves and let that
non-reaction thing you're talking about,
they're like,
I wasn't pissed off with him and he's just doing his job,
whatever.
But yeah,
there's something that happens when you do that and they treat you different.
Yeah.
It's possible to turn a situation around with the right attitude.
It's like there's a lot of people that we all know that always got into trouble
and you always had to look back and go,
could that motherfucker have avoided that trouble?
Like what did that shit really have to go down?
And they lay man,
if you would've done the same thing if you were in that situation and then you
go,
I don't know if I would have.
Right.
I don't know if I would have,
I think maybe you caught us.
Maybe it caused her a little bit.
Well and those kinds of reflections that you wouldn't be present to without
that.
You know what I mean?
And until you empty it out everything else and you're like,
oh,
this is another occurrence.
What I think of it all the time is,
is in myself.
It's not just how I reflect to the world,
but like how do I feel about it?
Like if somebody like somebody at my gym,
they didn't show up for class one morning and then there's no classes and people
are there and it's like a freak out,
you know?
But like,
and somebody said,
God,
you,
you react,
reacted.
You were just,
you're like,
okay,
well I know that it's got,
it's gotta be gutting for you.
I'm sorry that happened.
Let's look at how we can mitigate the,
the response of everybody else here and go on with them.
They're like,
what happened?
There's nothing.
You're,
you,
you in such a nice way.
And I'm like,
well,
it doesn't change anything for me to get all like all amped up about it.
And so why?
Why do I want to feel ugly inside?
Why do I want to have that?
That kind of cause that's a damper on your soul,
man.
And I'm like,
I can be happy or I can be shitty.
I'm going to choose to be happy about it.
The only time it becomes a problem is when you actually have to deal with
someone.
Like it's like they're being aggressively cunty.
Yeah.
I've got a great story with
the Hallway Story.
Oh yeah.
We were in a,
this is a perfect example,
it tapes,
but that's a good thing.
Listen,
I'm going to put up with,
this is a perfect example of,
it's like Jujitsu.
I feel like Jujitsu is like,
I'm going to dig you some holes and I'm going to offer you a bunch of bad
choices and you're going to have to go on one of my holes like the and and so
the same thing.
As long as everybody's clear about this is an eventuality that will happen if
you choose doré.
So that's all I'm going to say.
I let people make their own choices.
I'm here for whatever kind of party you want to throw.
We were hanging out in Las Vegas and I know that if you've ever been to Las
Vegas,
he know that there's some dudes that just don't know how to,
yeah,
they can do it.
You give him too much freedom,
too much booze.
This kid was like six foot six.
He was really exhilarating.
It was a big fuck.
And because of that he was like super confident that he could just go around
pushing people around and even Tate like taints a big motherfucker.
I wouldn't minister this stupid Dick.
He was probably like four or five inches taller than you.
Right.
He's a big boy fucker.
He was big.
His buddy
my size,
his buddy was,
and that was like normal.
And then there's this giant with him and we come out of the hotel
coming out on the elevator and take trying to put his card in the room and the
kids like,
that's my room and tell you,
it's like,
oh no,
I'm pretty sure it's mine.
Look.
Yup.
See I got the key,
take it easy.
Like literally like give the kid all the fucking room in the world.
And uh,
I was in the room next to him and all of a sudden we hear bang,
Bang,
Bang.
So after take one in his room,
that dude like decided that he was pissed off and he knew Tate was in there.
She's banging on the door to get taped,
come out.
So Tate opens a door and I hear them talk and Eddie and I run out into the
hallway.
And so this big fuck is standing in front of Tate.
And there was a lot of talking,
but nothing that looked like nothing was going to happen.
And the guy started to back away.
And Eddie Bravo goes,
well,
you're the one just standing there talking shit,
right?
There's the,
the guy,
the guy's friend is,
is more sober,
cooler.
And he's like,
hey dude,
come on.
Let's just go,
man.
Let's go.
And he's trying to get him to the elevator and our doors right where it t's off.
And so I'm looking out the window,
there's elevator elevator,
and then we're standing there and Eddie's over here and Joe's over here kind of
flanking me.
And,
and I was like,
dude,
just relax.
It's my room,
you know,
and all that.
And the guy's like,
yeah,
let's go.
And he turns to his friend and he,
and he shoves him,
his friends back on his shoulders inside the elevator at that point.
So at that point,
those cameras caught that.
And then the,
and then the
guys going,
you fucking baldheaded had [inaudible] son of a bitch,
all this kind of stuff.
All right,
dude.
Cool.
I said,
we're done.
Are you going to go?
And he's like,
no,
fuck you bitch.
And I'm like,
I was,
I dunno.
I just started hanging out with Joe Really?
And I was like,
you know what,
there's not a present danger.
What can I really do hear?
You know?
And,
and,
and Eddie was just like,
Eddie just dropped the leash and he was like,
what dude?
You're,
you're,
you calling him a bitch,
you're the one that keeps backing away,
whatever.
And I'm like,
I guess it's on,
right fucking.
Oh.
And then the dude comes at me.
I was like,
yeah,
come at me.
See what happens.
Let's go swing on me.
And then the dude stepped forward,
hit them with an inside leg kick and then hold guard.
He pulled guard wrap is dude up an Alma Plata so quickly that too,
had no idea what the fuck was going on.
He was drunk off his ass.
He couldn't believe what was happening.
He had this dude's feet in his face.
Okay.
And then,
um,
I don't know who said it or security guard.
The security guard came here.
Why was all going on?
And I said,
dude,
relax.
I said,
don't worry about.
I go,
he's going to be fine.
He's not going to hurt him.
He's just going to put them to sleep and then take over.
I guess I'm going to put them to sleep.
There's my boss.
I got to put them to sleep and I'll say,
I got to transition.
So Tate,
while he still has the duty to normal plot,
does sinks a rear naked on him and chokes him out.
Oh,
it was ruthless.
And then so he gets away and didn't hurt him at all.
Didn't the guy didn't get hit nothing.
You were so kind to him,
you know?
And then he wakes up,
his friends get them up and they pick them up.
They push them in an elevator.
He has no idea what happened.
He's like,
what happened?
What happened?
They all go in the elevator.
The elevator door shuts.
He disappears from life.
That's it.
Thanks us.
And all we could size is like,
that dude is probably picks on his friend.
He picks on everybody.
I like that all the time.
She was so ruthlessly douchey and drunk,
but he was a giant,
giant mother fucker and I guess he just thought that he could just get away with
doing that.
But that's how the universe works.
If you're a big giant evil motherfucker,
you run into a dude like Tate is bumps in the road,
bitch.
It's true.
That happens with road rage a lot.
Like I've got this mini Cooper now.
Before that it was a bowling ball and dude's trip.
And then I'll wait in the parking lot or whatever,
where I'm going to go into a store and they pulled around and then I pop out and
like,
hey,
how are you doing?
And you having a good day and night.
All the windows out of there.
Get back in their car now.
Like big giant,
bald,
tattooed do with a fucking pirate beard.
A little mad.
I'm like,
you were expecting my mom or a little kid or something to get old.
The son of a bitch.
And then you're going to bully him and now it's a gorilla.
So what you need to get a shit?
People get real identical.
I should meet.
They're driving.
You know it's because there's a disconnect that doesn't happen when it's just
people to people.
When it's people to people out there in the street,
it's very rare.
You'll find a guy like that bridge bag from that hotel.
It's very rare when you think of all the interactions you have with people.
But when you rent cars,
men,
so many fingers are flying so many fuck you's so many.
I'm looking at someone mouth thing,
fuck you to me.
And I'm like,
oh great,
great fuck you.
What?
Because what is it?
Cause I didn't let you cut in front of me or because you're driving like a dick
head and I'm trying to avoid you.
Like which one is it scary?
I love that whole idea of like I used to get mad if I'm trying to hold my place
and then I was like,
what are you hanging on to?
How about you can choose right now,
let him in Tate and then you're a hero.
You know what I mean?
I can and then everybody,
it's all good.
And when it doesn't happen,
the other side,
you're like,
seriously,
like you've got to block this is several feet.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's just not safe.
Like someone's trying to move and they were like trying to get you to move back
to like,
look,
what are you fucking doing?
You driving like a dick man.
I'm not going to let you in if you're driving like a deck,
you know,
just calm the fuck down.
Yep.
All that stuff is like reptile and then million survival fight or flight stuff.
Yeah.
Generally like when,
when I involve the,
a situation like that,
I usually just lay back.
I just start going even like below the speed of them and like just go on just to
get the fuck away from me.
Go ahead and go down your road.
Yeah.
But I feel like it's theirs.
Every now and then there's a guy behind the wheel,
it's driving so fucking crazy.
Some asshole.
The other day,
uh,
in the valley and like Encino was driving a Mercedes.
I've never seen anybody drive like this and like really crowded streets.
I mean,
he was just fucking nailing it and swerve and in between cars,
car to car to car to car.
I mean you had to be going a hundred miles an hour plus on a busy street.
It was really crazy.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of Douche bags out there.
So I,
I decided I try to work on this calmness and all that.
And for me,
driving and road rage was the worst.
I used to have the worst road rage ever.
Really?
Oh Dude,
I was terrible man.
You would not,
you're not recognize me.
I once got taken to the police station because someone accused me is,
this is a while back,
but they accuse me of a exposing myself well driving.
Uh,
and what the truth of the matter is that someone cut me off and I got pissed off
and I said,
you don't want it,
you know,
Hong Kong Bobo here and uh,
so uncommon Bobo here,
you made a,
you made it like a blow job,
sort of a case against you.
And I'm like,
yeah,
here you go.
Write us a new hash.
You exactly.
Hong Kong,
you said the people while they were driving,
I made that I made the,
the,
the graphical motion to have them blow you.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Like basically,
you know,
blow me f you.
And uh,
so what did the same
exactly.
Anyway,
I was kind of like,
I forgot about it and this police officer leaves her business card on my,
my front porch and apparently whoever cut me off,
it was just a complete idiot of a driver and like really apparently thought I
did this.
So this,
this little police officer,
woman is like,
Hey,
uh,
I know at the beginning of a porno,
I swear to God,
like in the police station,
she's like,
I know,
I know you did it.
And I started laughing.
I looked for cameras.
So I thought it was a joke.
Like I thought some friends of mine had really seriously hooked me up on this
because there's no way it was so far from my reality.
And she goes,
no,
I know you did.
I have witnesses and I'm like,
you can't have witnesses.
It didn't happen like you're lying.
And we went back and forth for two hours about this.
This is how bad my road dredge was.
Two hours she was full on,
I'm going to go to the DA.
I'm like,
you can't go to the DA.
There was no evidence.
And furthermore,
anatomically,
okay,
this is my lap,
this is the side of the car and this where the steering wheel is.
So unless I'm like hung like a horse,
it is not possible to drive and expose yourself at the same time.
I'm in the car next to you.
I'm like,
you can't do that.
So finally I did this lie detector test and I passed out and do a lie detector.
I volunteer to go.
I'm like,
I got,
there's nothing going on here.
Larry was so gestapo like,
can't even tell you.
But that's how bad my road rage was.
Like,
no wait.
He had to go to the station to get it light or did they have a lie detector?
You're testing the car?
Uh,
James got one.
Oh No,
this is bad.
This is a month after it happened.
Like,
Oh shit.
It was scary actually.
I was,
I realized I was absolutely guilty,
frightening rotary story ever.
Sure
are finally horrible New Mexico,
a couple of buses that are really Nice restaurant at your animal there.
They're driving home and they live like 20 minutes out of town in a little town
and there there's some road rage thing happened in at midnight or one in the
morning,
trouble in New Mexico.
Road rage is crazy.
I grew up there and uh,
and so anyway,
they get away from this car that is and,
and they're,
they're like stalking them.
It's like you can't go slowly,
they're going to slow down.
He can't go through faster and all that shit.
Right.
They pull off their exit and they go home and they're two brothers and their,
I don't know,
20 to 25 in there and they go into their house and then a car pulls up,
lights are on.
Hey motherfuckers,
we know you're in there and hey,
we know you're at something like that,
right.
And they say,
Hey,
fuck you,
we got a gun.
They've got a shotgun in there and don't,
and get the fuck off our property please.
Next thing,
you know,
Ding,
Ding.
One of the brothers takes one in the head and drops the other brother goes,
holy fuck,
and runs out the back door.
It's two state cops that have opened fire and then their hunting him.
He won't come out until he,
here's the comps,
here's more cops come.
And then he comes out and he goes to jail,
sits for the weekend.
He gets charged with resisting arrest.
A few things on him or whatever.
The state cops that killed his brother don't even get suspended.
I don't think they're there.
The brothers of the girl that was road raging them,
they call up the brother.
They're on the job and that's how New Mexico is too.
It's like fucking this serious grotesque.
This girl who was road rage roles,
rotation,
her brother,
others speaking assholes.
Fucking a road rage in me.
Come and arrest them or scare them.
So the cop goes,
oh fuck,
whatever.
I'll go pull over and it escalates to that.
Whoa.
No repercussions.
The brothers traumatized forever.
God bless him.
I mean the whole thing.
I'm like,
and that's what can happen.
You know,
what is,
what are you thinking is that causes people to do that in a way that they very,
very rarely do and person and the cop would probably never behaved that way
otherwise.
And just all these series of events happened and Kaboom.
Do you think we're not designed to interact with people being close to them?
It's not that the,
the mammal brain that you've got is 10 times faster than you can think about
stuff.
So you know,
you should do something,
but the reaction you get to someone cutting in front of you,
it's the same thing like a laboratory throw a piece of meat in front of it.
It eats it before it really knows what's going on.
So there's this whole set,
even though it could be poisonous or whatever though.
Exactly.
So,
so the reason we get in trouble,
almost everything we do is what dogs do,
right?
Like,
oh,
there's a leg all hump it,
there's a stick,
I'll chase it.
This distractability right?
And then,
oh,
there's a cat poop and I'll eat it.
Those are the three big behaviors that mess everyone up because all of them
happened 10 times faster than you think about them.
So for me,
road rage was like one of the last things to go and this was still a problem.
Number two,
the eat and cat poop.
Did you ever see your dog?
They think if you're a dog,
I don't know if you've ever been around dogs.
I mean it doesn't matter what it is.
So like basically later it's like it's covered in glitter bulldog that would do
that and I'd pull it out of his jowls and I was like,
oh,
I don't know what work or task you eating it or me pulling it off buddy.
But that's,
that's like the wiring in your brain that you share with all these other
animals,
right?
Someone cuts in front of you.
It triggers that,
trigger it in,
in that way in a car.
Why is it in the car?
Why is it so intense?
Is it the stress of driving and dealing with a bunch of people?
We get self absorbed.
I think it's an arrogance that I go,
I'm going somewhere.
And you're in my path of getting there.
Something like that.
And we don't get more open.
And when you,
when you drive that fast,
you have to have that part of your brain turned on because it's reaction time is
10 times faster than you can think about it.
Imagine if every time you want to put the brake on and you had to go,
I guess I'll think about whether I should put the brake on.
I guess I'll think and maybe I'll do some math to figure out how much time I've
got it.
So you're driving using your nervous system,
not using your conscious brain.
So you're reacting with your nervous system there.
So I finally hooked to actually putting in Reps.
It's like when I pulled guard on that dude,
all we've been,
all we've been drilling was going into that Omoplata like I can't,
if I drive him back,
we'd go through the window,
I can just do it and I just went there.
But it's like it's putting in the reps the same thing.
Where did you get to a kickboxing?
It's like,
I need this,
I need this to be second nature that I'm going to protect myself.
You know,
and,
and that's going on.
Interesting.
I hooked a sensor up to my ear when I was driving.
I did this for about two weeks and every time I fight or flight response gets
kicked off,
it turns red.
So when I put it there on the dashboard and I'd drive there in Silicon Valley
and in bad traffic,
every time someone cut me off,
my nurses would be like,
kill him.
Like you could see it turn red.
So then I'd make it turn green and after about a week I learned I could just
keep that thing green.
It didn't matter what anyone did,
but I had to train that part of myself just like you train a dog,
I don't have any road rage now.
I don't care what someone does in the road,
I'm not gonna get mad.
And like that's is having a spiritual consciousness like that where I go
regardless of my external conditions,
I'm,
I'm again,
I'm going to be unchanged inside.
Like that's the goal.
But you have to get conscious to that.
You can't,
if you're not a thinking person,
you're default is rage.
Perhaps there's an iPhone app for that now.
Like that's how insane this stuff is.
That's why I love this stuff because this isn't an iPhone APP for road rage.
It's an iPhone app for what I did there.
That thing that I clicked on my ear.
If all you do is you breathe in and breathe out it space as you're breathing and
tells you when your heart rate changes,
like an animal going into fight or flight.
As soon as that change happens is second by second change,
you just,
Oh look,
it happened again.
I guess I'll turn that off.
And after a while your,
your nervous system gets tired of going into fight or flight and getting no
satisfaction.
So it just stops.
Just like so just in recognizing it,
it,
it allows you to control it to a point where you can stop it from happening.
Just two steps.
The first is there's a feeling when it happens that you don't know what that
feeling is unless you're trained to sense it.
So first you know the feeling and then you know how to turn it off and they're
like different skills.
That was a beautiful thing because I mean like a heightened accountability
because so often we go,
oh well I'm powerless over what I eat or I feel like that are just my feelings.
But to really get super accountable for like,
this is my life,
these are my emotional,
and I can change all that.
And knowing they happen,
they happen before you can think about them and it doesn't matter what they are
because they're not really you.
They're just like an automated defense system.
Makes Sense about driving,
putting you in that heightened state.
Yeah,
totally.
Completely make sense.
Because you're going fast and you have to think quickly.
A friend of mine used to say,
he says,
you're,
you're not responsible for the first thought,
but you're responsible for stroking it.
After that,
it's like shit's gonna pop in your head.
That's a good friend.
Whatever you're going to,
whatever you're gonna do.
After that with it,
you can either say,
okay,
I'm going to go with this thought and coax it up into a huge problem or
whatever.
Yeah,
it's really important evaluation of your situation,
especially thinking about it that way,
thinking about the fact that you're,
you're on a very sort of animalistic high rev state because you're driving a
car.
That actually really makes sense.
My feeling was always that it was,
there was not enough connection between people that are in cars.
Like you don't feel bad if you cut them off the way you would feel bad if he did
something to someone in the grocery store.
Yeah.
Like if you kind of got off of the grocery store with your cart and you stuck
right behind them in line,
you would feel fucking terrible,
you know?
Right.
But if you cut a guy off in a car,
it's like this slow bitch.
It's just in a way it doesn't even bother you.
Yeah.
I just want to get past you'd stupid.
It's uh,
for,
for whatever reason,
especially for men,
I think it's just easier to be Dickey.
I see a lot of women tweak and cars to,
well everybody that they shouldn't drive.
I had an ex girlfriend that was nuts in her fucking cough.
She would cut dudes off.
They cut her off and she would do it with you in the car.
I mean,
it was like a fucking competition with her.
And you know,
she likes guys fight.
That's who that is.
Oh yeah.
She was crazy.
She was great.
But she was crazy.
But uh,
yeah,
I have to tell her,
stop,
I'm going to get out of your car.
I hate it when anyone kind of die.
I'm like,
you're going to get shot.
You don't know who you're dealing with.
You've had some thing about being a woman too.
You don't know who's going to follow you home gifts,
gifts,
give the wrong guy the finger and watch life,
get terrified
the hat.
But when you're a super aggressively douchey driving that way,
like you could pick the wrong guy and you don't want that person in your life
ever.
And all of a sudden now they're in your life in a very even and very intense
way.
Now you've invited the men.
That's a stupid idea.
It's dumb.
And that's comes from,
I think a lot of women.
It's,
it's very rare for them to experience firsthand violence.
Yeah,
no,
I mean I think you got,
uh,
the possibility of sexual stuff and you know,
things along those lines like from men.
But I think like men probably see a lot more physical violence like young men.
Not Anymore.
You don't think so?
I don't that,
do they have cops in schools now?
When I was a kid,
I kind of like 75 fist fights because you're still getting in fight.
So it seems like you're still dicky each other.
It's important though to,
I think it was part of growing.
I remember the first time I got socked in the mouth and I was like,
Oh shit,
that's very real.
You know what I mean?
And I was like,
and I needed that,
pat me in the face like that.
And,
and I,
and you can just see the dudes too that are in their 20s and you're like,
that guy never got punched in the face.
I bet.
Yeah,
and that's the problem he's having today,
currently,
right now in front of me.
Absolutely.
That's all a lot of,
well,
a lot of guys too.
It's like you're,
you're whole stupid body's designed for chaos and the chaos and never shows up.
It's like you're just work all day.
Where's this chaos?
I'm designed for this,
this mad world that I like.
You know,
if you're,
uh,
if you're fucking a healthy male,
life can be challenging.
You know,
if you're a healthy testosterone film mail and you don't have a release,
if you don't have something that lets you burn off energy,
well guess what?
This,
the world doesn't need you like that.
You know,
you're,
you're stuck in a situation where you're,
you're bouncing around in a world that doesn't need cavemen anymore.
What to do,
what to do.
They're also used to be like a rite of passage,
like the ceremonies to tell you like you're in a dollar.
You've got accurate once you're 18 you can vote.
You can't drink.
Sorry,
but there's nothing else.
I think that's big.
We've talked about that before.
I think there needs to be a rite of passage for men,
you know,
and it should be something that you,
I mean it,
whether it's a physical accomplishment or a mental accomplishment,
it's almost like graduating,
like graduating from high school.
If you graduated from high school,
I know.
Well at least the guy graduated from high school.
She graduated from college.
Like wow.
Having graduated from college,
they should be.
I graduated from med school.
I went to band school.
I is a two week course.
Everybody designed to take it.
Let's see if you call that like boy scouts,
but who goes into this house?
Looks fast.
I did like the boy scouts.
Brian.
I in the boy scout scout too.
But how many you eagles?
That's the most important one.
I quit like the month after I became one os patch.
Yeah,
it's a big deal.
Become an eagle scout.
I remember.
I'd see guys that did it.
Yeah.
I did one year in the boy scouts.
The Boy Scouts in Jamaica Plain.
It was a fucking sketchy area outside of Boston.
And I went to the woods of New Hampshire with fucking criminals.
That's what it was.
It was me and a bunch of kids who want to fucking criminals.
And they were ganking kids the middle of the night,
they were tying them to their bed,
covering them with toothpaste.
It was some shit like you had to be on point at any moment.
You might have to be wrapped with some kids you don't even know well from an
even worse neighborhoods.
Yeah.
I barely remembered mine.
Like it was a church based boy scouts too.
Most of it.
And so I don't know if I was just molested while being a boy scout.
And that's why I don't remember.
Cause I should remember more from being a boy scout.
Could you imagine one day you will like masturbating or something and then you
had this flash in front of your face of,
of uh,
a priest cock right before your mouth and you went,
I knew it.
I knew there was something I was missing.
Yeah.
Or that's why I've never been to like a football game or a baseball game with,
you know,
my uncle because maybe every time I see
flashes of a whole locker room full of football players throwing a pounding to
you,
it's a dark mystery.
Slashes.
No denying it.
Flash flash
pens over there.
I had a friend on ecstasy at 25 tripping right in the middle of like a first
time I used the,
uh,
it all came back to him.
Absolutely remembered he'd been abused for like eight years.
Knocked out that that shouldn't happen.
It does.
It's real.
Yeah.
Those repressed memories is scary stuff,
Matt.
Yeah.
So every time Brian takes me,
it's just like therapy.
He's just trying to get to the root of thing.
Boils down to the same thing.
It's Shitty.
Humans create shitty humans.
You know,
so many shitty humans have created more shitty humans because of the shittiness
thing too is like you got it.
Like when you're talking about there's no right of passage or there's no man's
school or it's like I sometimes,
like a little while ago I did a self defense thing down on the bluffs for people
and always is shocking to me of like here's a bunch of grown people that don't
know the first thing about how to take care of themselves in a physical.
It should be a responsibility.
It should be responsibility to know like that's why I'm so like a fan of Dave's
or rob wolf or mark Sisson and all those guys.
It's like it's a responsibility to know how to take care of your body and to
know how to,
to know how this thing operates and all that and what it's capable of.
And also I think as a man,
it's your responsibility to take care of weaker people or women or whatever like
you.
You should know those,
you should know those things.
You should know math,
you should know how to read.
You should know how to draw a pic.
You should try all that shit.
You should have a true liberal education and there's not a set up for that.
Maybe know how to say,
if you can't meet a button on yourself,
please stop embarrassing yourself.
Get it together.
This isn't like a,
there's a weird intellectual thing where people like to pretend they don't care
about their body.
Like they're above it.
Yeah.
So it's actually going to fuck you.
Well,
yeah.
This is,
there's a thing,
a manly thing about being a fat fuck.
You don't give a shit and you just let your,
your gut grow at all.
Like a boss.
Yeah.
That would be like,
you know,
a picture of you,
what?
Your gut hanging over your belt.
Like a boss,
like a boss.
But the people who listened to your show,
I don't get the impression there's a lot of that going on.
Like some people that do,
I'm sure you know,
it just,
it takes all kinds of people in all kinds of different,
you know,
some people absorb some things and some people did some parts about their life,
they just don't want to change
or they haven't mustered up the urge to change it yet.
You know,
but there's also a lot of people that listen to this podcast where I have the
mountain.
They were like,
I lost a hundred pounds since I started listening to the podcast stuff.
All that.
That's fucking crazy.
That's insane.
Crazy.
When,
I mean you talk about bulletproof coffee,
put that out there and I don't know if you ever have yet,
but like to put out a thing about like what are your results?
The results are fucking astonishing.
Hundreds,
the breadth of them is incredible and those are just people that we'll talk
about it and a lot of it's like up here,
like I'm getting a mental focus and the energy and and brand quality natural
speed dude is
talking about like it's so much,
it's awesome.
But B,
people that get off of Paxil,
Zoloft,
shit like that that are like,
I just feel more,
even all the time now that I eat a high high level of fats all the time in my
system or whatever.
It's like that's when people don't think that that's the heaviest drug that
you're taking most.
I mean a couple people here excluded perhaps,
but like food is maybe the number one ha,
heaviest drug that anybody takes in the world and we do it all the time without
thinking about it.
And I would just have you consider that if you think about it just a little bit,
you can have a drastically different experience with life.
There's so many people that have a nutrient deficient life and it's really
terrible or sugar independent or whatever.
Your moods are up and down.
When I went to just all fats basically like,
dude,
I'm even,
I'm like,
wow,
like all day long,
I feel great even and I don't have these horrific mood swings,
you know,
and bagels lost their power,
didn't they?
Oh God.
There's none of that.
Just are out of your fucking mind.
I will never lose the love for Bagels,
some lox and cream cheese.
Talk to me.
Brian and I did have some [inaudible] I need to Goddamn cheat day.
No croissants with chocolate will fuck a big dude over on third street.
There's a great spot.
The Real French folks.
Not that they're useful for much else,
but making croissants.
They're good.
Do you rocket cheat,
Dang.
Do eat healthy.
That was the first time that I had wheat and two years was I wouldn't have those
croissants and yeah,
I just don't fuck with it.
I don't know if I,
if it's not going to make me feel better or perform better,
I got zero use for it.
It's a funny one Max.
People think you fucking crazy for saying that.
Weed's bad for you.
Horrible.
Especially when you start looking at it like the advent of Gliadin or things
like that that are in wheat now.
Like it's fucking crazy.
My chiropractor or a friend actually who's a chiropractor told me that one of
the reasons why people get an inflammation as far as like disks,
things like that.
She's like,
we've been able to help people launch just by cutting wheat out of their diet.
Like that's insane.
More known cause they trade it on the fucking stock exchange because there's big
money in it.
I mean there's a reason why the FDA or whatever.
It's like,
well,
it's also nine to 12 servings a day.
It's so yummy.
Okay.
It's not just as bad.
I love
Spaghetti and you can go first.
I will love Spaghetti
squash with some meat sauce over the top.
Ended off,
fuck.
I'm tired ass shit.
He start this banana sense,
absolute talking
nonsense out of your fucking mind.
Wheelhouse slams a little linguine with clams or light sauce.
Fucking sense squash.
I like a light sauce with linguine and clams.
A little,
a little bread with some butter on the side.
Whites.
No
tape.
My queef proof.
You were telling me that there's a a way to upgrade my Kale shake.
What does it Bruce,
that was to kill shake upgrades.
I wrote a post for you guys.
Here's the thing about rock Kale and it's full of oxalic acid,
which is what makes kidney stones.
Oh,
and maybe on you bitch.
I don't want those.
I've only got,
I've only got one kid so I know about this stuff.
Wow.
So,
um,
gave me other shakes.
Can give you a kidney stones as well.
Take my notebook.
Oh,
I'm going to tell you how to fix it.
Okay.
So I did a bunch of research cause I was a raw Vegan,
like I've had more than my fair share of Kale waiting.
Will you?
A road raging,
raw vegan.
I was a road raging ravigo absolutely events.
I've tried everything I can find Julie on the side.
It's an odd one.
And the tape,
oxalic acid,
that's oh x a l I c I take somebody taking notes.
I just put a post up with the recipe for this,
but I'll walk you through why it works.
So oxalic acid also is tied to Vulvodynia,
which is painful sax.
It's,
it's basically extreme sensitivity of the vagina in women.
And what happened?
No concern to me.
Trust me.
You are married to someone with it.
It would be,
oh,
you're so sweet.
Uh,
it's more,
but sex is this,
what if you call your effects also if you're juicing it or only if you're
blogging,
if you're juicing it,
it doesn't matter either way.
So it turns out that this is the way that the plant protects itself.
So for B,
Yeah.
So basically if you're a Kale,
you don't want to get eaten by snails and bugs and you're nice soft green plant,
so you put this stuff in you.
It's the same thing that like aspergillus and Candida that mold to give you
yeast infections.
Those things also make oxalic acid is one of their ways of protecting their
turf.
So we had something like that and it to where it attacks your bowels as you're
digesting it.
It,
it's a different chemical and wheat,
but it's the same idea like most starch sources and a lot of like soft green
vegetables have a defense mechanism and a salary.
It's nitrite,
but here it's oxalic acid.
So in Vulvodynia what they believe,
and this is a sort of a mystery illness,
but what they believe,
at least in one group of researchers is that this stuff,
the acid form of oxalic acid gets into the body and it goes into tissues
including muscles and your GI system and things like that.
It complexes with calcium and then it forms a little crystals kind of like gout
does,
and then this is a trigger.
There's also a group of people looking into oxalic acid is one of the
contributors to autism.
Whoa.
So I'm not saying you can't eat kale when I'm smell shakes could turn you
autistics is that what you just said?
That's not what I can,
can you just sing to the cow first and like relax it and the throat in your
mouth real fast before it finds out it's getting eaten.
Uh,
you,
you could try that.
So here's what you do.
Yeah,
that's what you do.
Poison Bryan.
Talk Nice to
you.
Picked Dinosaur Kale instead of curly,
frizzy cow.
Because Dinosaur Dinosaur Kale,
it's called,
it has like bigger,
broader leaves that are less ridged and it was kind of like you'd imagine
dinosaurs can,
would look instead of like the real frilly stuff.
Where do you find that shit?
You find it at whole foods.
There's different varieties that frilly shit.
Yeah.
No,
Lacey Kale.
That's why we have an aversion to lace the coolest clothes,
but put laces all of them.
I'm like,
bitch,
what are you doing day Romaro and then you'll wear that.
You take girl wears the same shorts and you put lace on them and you're like,
oh,
look at this dirty bitch.
I see a little lace at the bottom of the shorts.
You could the,
the lease could actually make the shorts a little longer,
but you see the lady,
she's like,
oh,
look at this little dirty bitch walking around with Lacey.
We get the vegans that they've actually put Kale on their shorts and they get
all excited about that.
Do they do this weird cats does that in the carry your pants?
He just happened to see me.
All right,
so you picked the right kind of Kale.
It's going to cut your oxalic acid by about half.
Then you steam it,
cook it a little bit.
Listen,
you've cooked it a little bit,
you know,
dumped the water,
dump the water because the water is what absorbs the oxalic acid.
So you get rid of two thirds of the oxalic acid.
That way you keep the vitamin K and you increase the bioavailability of the
other stuff in there.
When you boil it,
it doesn't,
when the water comes off of that doesn't take vitamins out of it.
It doesn't take many vitamins.
It takes more oxalic acid than it does by.
Be careful of how long you boil it.
You want,
yeah,
you just want to boil it for like five,
seven minutes studies.
Like how did they,
uh,
they test this.
There's two of them.
There's two of them up there.
Basically oxalic acid awareness foundations and guys like that.
I don't have the exact name.
I reference it on my blog bite.
I linked to the original studies.
So,
so what you do is you boil it,
toss it in the blender,
Kale,
check this out though.
You can still have Kale.
Kale is good for you.
So you take,
it's become a process.
You gotta steam it.
It's like five minutes.
It's just this much water.
Throw the candle.
If I only have a Kale shake once a week,
how much you know much what to do if you're like in the month,
it is cumulative so you have an oxalic acid burden in your body.
If you have like you know,
Dandruff and yeast problems,
that's going to raise your burden.
If you do other high oxalic foods,
that's going to be a burden.
So most people,
you're going to be fine if you do it once a week,
it doesn't matter.
But here's the trick.
If you're going to do it regularly,
boil it and do calcium loading,
which is a term that I just finally made up because there's two studies.
One,
they actually give calcium tablets to people when they eat Kale,
and 97% less oxalic acid goes into the system because it forms calcium oxalate
in the gut and you poop it out.
Instead of getting it in your kidneys,
are you getting it somewhere else in your body?
Or there's another study that says mineral water full of minerals.
If you do that,
it also reduces it.
So what I'm is we in the blender,
steam the stuff,
add butter,
add MCT oil to it,
add your hemp force protein,
any kind of protein you want.
You can still do the same thing.
Now it's a hot drink instead of a cold drink.
It's actually really good that way.
I,
I do it quite a lot even for lunch and then add a little bit of calcium to it.
You do that when you blend it,
the calcium is going to stick to the oxalic acid and when you're not gonna
absorb any of it,
so what are you going to get?
You get less muscle weakness,
which can happen if you get these crystals forming in your muscles and you're
going to get less risk of kidney stones and that kidney stones stuff.
There's solid research on that,
so you've got to put calcium in there.
Even if it's raw.
Blew my mind to all the people out there that have been eating Kale shakes every
day because of me.
No,
I'm not saying kills bad kills really good for it.
You're totally right people.
Do you think you're going to have an issue with this is a small percentage?
No,
I think it's a big percentage,
but you don't know like Vulvodynia is considered a mystery condition.
Maybe it's emotional.
Maybe you should never eat raw kale.
Then when Ross finish is just as bad rust,
calcium,
you should be substance.
You should have that in your diet anyway.
Even if you take Zma and all that,
you need to take calcium.
I don't suggest supplemental calcium for anyone unless you're doing something
like Kale shakes.
Most people need magnesium.
There are way too high in calcium.
If they eat almost everything.
I take Zma all the time,
but good,
I wouldn't do calcium.
Then your body needs a two to one ratio of calcium to magnesium.
So just take magnesium.
You've got enough calcium,
there's not a problem unless you're pregnant or you're dealing with like,
you know,
osteoporosis and even osteoporosis.
You need k,
two vitamin D,
stuff like that.
Much more than you need.
Just extra calcium.
The calcium doesn't stop osteoporosis by itself.
Okay,
so for the record,
if you want to drink kale six you should drink it with calcium,
with calcium and magnesium.
Actually take a bullet for five minutes or five minutes,
steam it,
steam or boil.
It seems better I think,
and then just drain off that water that's done,
that's there.
Toss it in the blender and there's the hostile water and the throw the throw the
water out,
but towards the calendar,
I'm telling you when you do it with butter and MCT oil and you just blend it,
it's like the hot creamiest soup.
Like I love it and I put like upgraded Collagen in it.
I'd put the MCT in there.
So you're still getting,
the fats are getting whatever protein you want you can do with him for us,
which is really delicious.
And all of a sudden then you're like,
wow,
I feel great and it takes no more time than making a cold smoothie with ice and
all that other crap and you're protecting yourself a lot from this oxalic acid
that's going to build up over time.
Wow.
That's a mindblower dude.
Why am I not hearing about this?
How come you're the guy out there?
I'm a bio hacker.
That's I think about this though.
But shouldn't that be,
I mean you think about how much people eat Kale these days.
It's so it's,
I think it was like a super food and they've been saying a lot,
Jay.
I've been saying you shouldn't eat raw kale.
I've been saying that for like the last couple of months.
I heard the same thing where the raw kale,
yeah,
you need to cook it first.
They were looking at something I route it was,
there was another issue.
There was a,
it was a different,
also bacteria.
It's just not healthy is there's bacteria also that grows on raw kale.
Oh,
it was wonderful.
It was raw vegetables.
I mean I just trying to figure out what the other thing was,
but it was a fungus that we were talking about.
Yeah,
that's a issue.
You get gut fungus going on it.
That stuff will ruin you and we don't even measure it.
We just figured out,
oh,
there's a whole bunch of fungus with all those probiotics in the gut.
And so when you're just stuff,
how should you boil everything that you're doing a little bit or what you should
boil everything that you do.
I'm not opposed to ignite salad.
Add some salad today.
So,
but raw vegetables for their own sake.
You've got to look at what that vegetable is.
A lot of stuff like a mock of root in Makkah.
It's really good for you.
But he got my coffee all the time.
You want to cook Maka route.
I actually it was about to launch Maca root.
Uh,
but the,
the source I had was super high end.
It was raw hand crafted,
all that stuff.
And then I did the research and it turns out Raw Makkah is not safe to consume
and traditional people always gelatin has it.
They cooked the heck out of it.
Yeah they cook it until it makes like a sticky gelatin cause the raw stuff has
all these like anti nutrients in it.
So what's the powder that I'm drinking?
I don't know if it makes sure it's processed.
Maka this Gel Tonies not the raw stuff.
Cause I also,
I sent mine through my lab because I test everything for mycotoxins.
13 parts per million of aflatoxins.
Got A lab.
It's awesome.
So I got a quick,
it's a Camry,
a lot of rappers
to Camry.
It's beautiful.
I mean my two two liter bottles,
I love the
sun
and so it's bad.
Obviously you run Mancha is,
yeah.
What about um,
celery fellow?
Real kitty is okay to eat raw ginger.
Ginger's okay.
Raw Ginger has problems with mold in it because it's a root in roots.
They spoiled,
right?
So if it's dried properly and harvested well it's great if it's,
if it's done right,
but if they cut corners like big food loves to do,
then you get all this stuff you're not supposed to be getting in your body.
Same thing with celery.
I just buy from the farmer's market.
That's fucking grocery store.
But you wouldn't know this,
but wild celery,
we'll can kill you.
It's so hostile.
I dare it.
Delta wild.
What does wild salary look like?
It looks just like normal salary,
but when bugs and stuff eat it,
it makes so many nitrates.
So when you bite it,
it's almost like a poison ivy.
Like it can cause swelling here.
So the celery that we eat as like treated gently.
So it doesn't make a lot of toxins to fight off bugs.
But you ever see that?
Like Bacon,
the real expensive bacon that's cured and they celery powder and the,
it's nitrate free.
It's total bs.
Salary is so high in nitrite,
not nitrate,
that when they powder the salary and they put that on the vacant and they're
doing the same thing as putting nitrate in there,
they just don't have to tell you it's nitrate.
So salaries,
the source of that nitrate isn't a problem unless you've got bad bacteria in
your gut.
That's not gonna be a problem if you're eating right.
But I thought there was like all these studies and so the nitrates are terrible
for it.
Well,
nitrates and nitrites,
it's bioabsorbables slight difference,
but the real difference is they're only bad for you if you have the bacteria in
your gut that make it bad for you.
So bad bacteria in your gut and make nitrosamines which mess you up.
But you can make nitros.
To me,
he's out of the gut too.
Like I cure my own bacon,
but I blocked and I trust him me information when I do it that way,
I would never talk to you.
If you're talking to a guy,
he's like a cure my own bacon.
But like bitch,
I got it.
Can
you tell the right kind of woman that you carry on Bacon?
And they're like,
I want to go home with you.
Oh
yeah.
Well you never do shack.
You can call them the right kind of women.
One of the definitions are honest about cholesterol.
Like I've been my own experiment now for some years.
And like you said,
starting out,
like I go pretty aggressively in deep into whatever it is and I'm like,
let's do this.
Then let's find out what happens.
And uh,
so a couple things would happen.
I want completely,
uh,
ketogenic for maybe six months.
Now what does that mean exactly?
Is that when you don't eat any carbs?
So that's the a hundred grams a day for a prolonged period of time,
like an Atkins style.
Is that
like that?
Here's the thing about Atkins,
Atkins Diet.
He just said eat less carbs,
but he didn't differentiate between types of fat and he let you eat way too much
protein because too much proteins inflammatory too.
So if you've got people on the Atkins Diet,
they lose half their weight and they get stuck and the second half won't come
off.
That happened to me.
I lost 50 pounds.
Is it gonna be another three or four years to get the other 50 off?
Cause I didn't understand moderate protein ketosis from eating not too many
carbs and a ton of the right kind of fat.
And when you do that,
your inflammation goes away and all of a sudden you can lose a hundred pounds.
Like I didn't keep it off for 10 years.
That's the trick.
I use it with that.
Then I find that after what happened for a while,
for me anyway,
was that for sure my cortisol level changed.
Like I got higher,
higher cortisol,
I got more stress like,
and,
and I,
it was,
it was like overtraining for me.
When you're overtraining,
one of the biggest things that you can find,
like if you're doing two or three days,
is that you'll wake up with your heart racing or something.
If you do that fucking,
you've got to pump the brakes.
You know what I mean?
You're,
you're just,
you're in a state where you need a few days off or whatever.
So the same thing was happening and it was just dietary for me and uh,
and so then I backed off and I do huge re feeds of,
of just cross and and things like that and fruit but a cycle in and out.
And what else should I have done and how long should he stay in Ketosis?
Like just a couple of weeks and then re feet or or what are you talking about?
I recommend for guys every seven to 10 days to refeed and for women as often as
every four days,
if they can get into ketosis between it,
women do not do well on,
on a little short time to get there isn't,
it takes like three days or something to get there.
Three or four days using MCT oil,
you're going to get justice real fast with it and stuff.
If not,
you go a little bit longer.
But with the coaching clients I've got the,
the women,
they tend to,
if they go in Ketosis and stay there,
they'd start not dreaming and they get more stressed and like their sleep
quality goes down and I did like three months of like one serving of vegetables
a day.
The rest was mostly fat and some meat and eggs and stuff like that.
It did not end well man.
After three months of that I was waking up nine times a night and not knowing I
woke up,
I was kind of like my sleep was dead and I started getting really dry eyes and
dry sinuses and I just didn't feel good so I found out what happened is that I
couldn't even tears because they didn't have enough carbohydrates to me.
Tears.
So you have to end my gut lining because you're a man,
you're not out there crying in human fuck and you didn't want to cry.
You're coming up with it.
That is what I see though with athletes too.
Without you guys suck,
man.
Female,
they wouldn't,
they need more carbs.
It's like they can get leaner with more carbs.
I think their cycle gets messed up if they go too low on carbs,
which is insane.
I can't believe you couldn't produce tears.
Yeah.
Well my eyes were dry and Mike Sinus is hurt and the lining of my stomach,
like your stomach has mucus.
Like they protects it from the acid that got dissolved.
I develop new allergies from three months of like zero carbs essentially.
So that a hundred grams a day actually matters.
And uh,
occasionally refeeding with like 500 or 800,
like go crazy and eat a lot of not wheat though.
We just a terrible way to refit.
It'll take you like a whole wheat sweet potatoes and squash and why Ryan is
actually can be good for you as long as you're cheating with foods that aren't
full of toxins like the Tim Ferriss towel cheat day where you just eat like
snickers bars and whatever.
I tried that for years and what happens is it takes you four or five days to
recover from the cheat day.
Cause we're not talking about just like losing a little bit of weight.
We're talking about like rocking everything and if you want your brain to work,
you want to not have road ranch and not be a dick when you don't want to be a
dick,
then I don't think that she did with cutting all the fun out of fucking cheat
Shit.
Did you just eliminate right there?
You know what's cool though is the tighter that my diet gets done,
the better.
What I'm willing to do a,
it's like before a pizza is to be a cheat day,
then it's now it's like sweet potato fries are,
yeah,
that was a norm.
It's like you get dialed in butter and you're just like,
I just,
this is why w how good do I want to feel?
And then you go,
fuck,
I don't feel good.
I just had a fight or that it went and he cut a bunch of weight and then he does
cake and all.
It's like I don't ever want to sacrifice how I feel to feel like this.
It feels so fucking horrible.
So what about cholesterol then?
Till now is 300 plus cluster.
I'll make sure mustache right now.
That's the first thing.
So what?
What are the things that you can eat if you want to have a cheat day?
I don't eat bad fats like hydrogenated fat,
corn oil,
canola oil,
and don't eat grain like don't eat wheat.
If you avoid those things,
you can have sugar on your cheat day,
that's fine,
but don't eat sugar and markers are cool.
It depends if you're sensitive to Casein,
the milk protein,
a lot of people should just not have milk and you're going to go right to sleep
afterwards.
If you're eating clean.
And I like,
if I go ahead and I'll go to the movies,
it might be worth it.
Oh,
it's great.
Really good ice cream Sundae,
isn't it?
You can feel it's very worth it to ice cream.
You can do ice cream.
That's insane.
The get some ice cream.
Do we talk about that last time?
Them ice cream.
It's a recipe for ice cream I made.
And especially for women when they eat it,
it's dumb.
Horny Guardian made this for me.
[inaudible]
was trying to get you horny dude.
Him and his Old Lady,
nobody asks and it was like purple or taller or rude or something.
It was the most delicious fucking ice cream.
They're like horn you and you haven't tried bulletproof ice cream yet.
Is that what you call it?
I called get some ice cream.
That's what Keith was calling it.
It's a bulletproof recipe,
but it's in my the upgrade shaft book and be on the menu.
So here's,
here's how it works.
You,
you put like nine egg yolks,
not the egg whites,
just the yolks.
Like you can give the whites to someone who owned it doesn't.
If it does your low fat stuff and then you put like chocolate and butter and
coconut oil and MCT oil and there's as much fat as you can fit in this ice cream
and you put it in the ice cream maker.
You can put whatever sweetener you want and their sugar salad,
tall,
whatever.
Oh honey.
Stevia.
Stevia is is really good.
I don't use sugar.
And when I do it,
I used out of the tall or cvs and you make the stuff and it sends an
environmental signal to both of you,
but especially the woman.
Her body is primed.
All women have this if there's still fertile,
and it says,
if I'm in a world where there's enough raw materials to make a super healthy
baby,
I should go to the bedroom and make one.
So you basically give this huge dose of amazing fast,
which the body craves.
And then what happens?
You go to the bedroom an hour later.
It's predictable and repeatable.
I mean,
Keith was saying it works,
right?
Yeah.
He'd like hundreds of people who try this.
It just doesn't mean that you have to come inside them either.
It doesn't mean like a roofie like effect,
because it's not fucking,
is that what you're doing?
Your roofing chicks with your ice cream?
No.
I'm telling you vodka versus get some ice cream.
You're going to score more if you make this ice cream.
Talking about Jack Daniels.
It depends what kind of growing up my awesome hippie ice cream is better than
fucking Tequila in terms of certain outcomes.
It works.
What about shitty decision making and good times.
Last [inaudible] got my boner for bad decision makers.
But you,
you've had this stuff.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's like,
okay,
so the full ingredients to brief people.
It's a egg yolks.
Egg yolks nine was a little ice cream maker.
A Cup of Kerry gold.
Unsalted butter.
Do not put salt in your ice cream.
It's gross.
Right?
Okay.
And then a cup of coconut oil,
half a cup of MCQ ice cream.
Those the shit like Carmel salt everywhere isn't so good.
And I try to add it to add it afterwards.
Okay,
so unsalted butter.
Yeah,
a cup of coconut oil.
Coconut,
about a half a cup of MCT oil,
which gives it like the creamy consistency.
I had to play around with the ratios there.
The ratio of butter in it.
Oh totally.
You melt the cow butter in it.
It's like eating like a,
almost like a moose when you put the in there.
It's,
it's so good.
Good.
So I made this.
All right,
so I'm going to pitch my book for five seconds.
Hold on.
Finish the thing.
So does it work?
The recipes in here and we're going to use this.
Leave us a cliffhanger.
We use it works.
I forgot how to make some healthy when you're like,
look,
you need to buy my book.
Now it's the recipes in the book.
But here's the thing,
we use it to turn my west fertility back on.
It is that powerful.
I made it for every night,
not just for fertility,
because it was fun too.
Um,
but I met for every night Mr Asprey without pictures listening.
She's going to kill me.
And by the way,
she,
she's listening.
Sorry.
Londa would just choke him around.
Mrs Bulletproof,
is there a rocky road?
Is,
do you call her bulletproof wife?
No,
but I will.
Now
that's not a bad idea.
That's the next book title.
Great.
Yeah.
Bulletproof wife sell that shit.
So it was it.
What does it,
the better baby book.
Yeah.
And it's all just about eating,
eating healthy fats.
I'm just eating.
Everything you can do to change with the environment tells the baby to do with
his jeans.
Upgrading your baby.
Fortunate story that was in the news about a Vegan couple that were arrested and
charged with the woman apparently didn't supplement with B 12 and the baby just
like almond milk and soy milk or something.
I felt awful when I saw that.
So fucking terrible lack of understanding of nutrition.
They were going out of their way to do vegetarian diets or anything like that
because they think it's a horrible thing to do.
They they're,
they think it's the higher consciousness like to,
do you know what I mean?
And that's let's,
let's talk about that.
Okay.
All right.
If you're Vegan and you're doing it for the environment,
you got to understand that hooved animals like cows and sheep are required for
soil to not turn into desert.
Cause if they don't break up the top of the soil and poop on it,
then the soil dies and it forms a crust of algae and water can't go into the
soil.
So we've had desertification problems,
like the great dust bowl and all that stuff that happened around the depression
happened because we killed all the buffalo.
So there's a need for us to have grass fed cows roaming ground.
So imagine imagined there's still buffalo that would suck a dick trying to drive
from New York,
California,
this fucking million buffalo making the way across the plains.
I just see big Ole steaks terribly the whole way.
Buffalo on the call,
there's so big and they don't even give a fuck if you're there because you're so
god Damn Ben.
I would have an awesome coat.
Some got it.
Some guy got fucked up by a buffalo recently.
Yellowstone.
I heard they're wicked smart like dogs too.
Like you could train them as a pet.
Ted Nugent had one and he would ride it on stage.
Ted,
he used to ride it onstage.
How crazy did he go?
I love him.
He's got a place in Michigan and a place in Texas.
Was that gaps in the high fence operations where just keeps animals in it except
cats.
No cats.
He does not like cats.
Oh yeah.
Was probably smart.
Right.
He talks about hunting them all the time.
Oh yeah.
Feral cats like no,
he,
she was like thousands of him.
He says,
look,
the killed on my birds and he texts him out at 500 yards.
That dude is,
he's,
he knows about the environment.
Yeah.
Steve Rinella.
The guy from that show meters go hunting and he used to kill feral cats as well.
We have a different understanding of what a cat is.
Then it would a feral cat is feral cat as a pet.
Yeah.
They're wild.
I mean it's not,
it's not what you think and they will kill your livestock.
They'll kill all kind of feel whatever they can as a high level predator.
Yeah.
You get chickens,
they'll kill your chickens for sure.
There.
Especially if you have a Tom cat,
one of those males,
the big heads and they come around and piss on everything.
When you can't usually get a male that gets out,
that's not fixed.
Those males get really big man.
Yeah.
Those,
some of those,
I like a goldfish effect.
Like,
if you can keep the goldfish in the bowl,
it gets so big,
but like you let that cat out,
it gets,
it turns doing huge car
foods that killing machines.
Yeah,
they killed like three birds a day.
Or the amount of feral cat
there are in the country is gigantic to folks.
I'll realize it.
Unless you're driving from New York to California,
you know,
you stop and some of these towns along the way,
but a lot of people just,
they're irresponsible.
They're fucking animals.
The cats get out.
They form communities,
they start,
they start organizing,
they make kittens.
The reservations are crazy for that throat.
Arizona and New Mexico.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure the people that live there,
it's like they don't want to neuter him.
Like there's drives to neuter and spay.
They're animals and they're like,
Hey,
don't neuter that though.
Like we were on set there and there's dogs that are dying and eating each other.
It's,
it's horrific.
And you're seeing straight rape scenes with dogs like on,
on if there's a dog in heat,
if there's a bitch in heat,
there's like 12 dogs,
right?
It's the most horrific thing you've ever,
it's bad.
And uh,
and,
and it's right here,
but we were taking one dog because it was tied up to a post and it was been shot
with arrows and it's getting like,
like just people,
people are kids are fucking with it,
torturing it,
right?
So we cut it off,
we asked to take it to the vet,
we take them to the vet and they're like,
yeah,
can you get the shots too and do it,
you know,
all this kind of thing.
And they're like,
but don't neuter it.
And we're like,
we're just taking the dog.
Like this is a dead animal.
And so one of the crew people ended up,
they said,
okay,
you can have it,
you know,
and they took it and they neutered it.
But there's something against that.
Like they don't want.
And I don't know why.
If they only live eight months probably there and they want a lot more around,
but it's bad.
Well,
there's a big problem with Toxoplasma in third world countries because of the,
cause.
There's so many.
It's really,
are we talking about and cats and pregnancy?
Is that what you're talking about?
In Brazil?
A long time ago,
the doctors will tell you never touched cat poop while you're pregnant.
And I think it's good advice.
It's great advice.
I'm talking about plans,
even if I'm not pregnant.
Bulldogs mouth,
that's the worst.
So I was told one of my gay friends,
I was like,
I figure it's just like that.
Like some guys just like dicks and it said it's like my bulldog.
He just liked catch it.
I didn't understand it.
I thought it was disgusting,
but I did that.
I was like,
I'm just not going to try to pull it out of his mouth though anymore.
So you just do your thing.
I don't want to know about that,
but never want to meet your dog.
Why don't you just cover the,
the like what?
What I do is I have like my,
well,
I had to go back to the wall.
I turned it to the wall so only the cat could fit in that we got from,
it was a learning process.
Brian Katz to cat poop.
I see the connection to the start with c connection.
This just shows chaos.
Going to cock next door.
There was a bunch of people the last time you were here.
First of all,
uh,
I,
I love the recipe for bulletproof coffee.
And what I love about it is because of all the fats in it,
the caffeine is on like sort of a slow drip.
That's,
I didn't figure that out.
I didn't understand that before.
I really paid attention after I was like,
why would it last longer?
Well,
that makes sense.
You're,
you're blending it up with all this grass fed butter and
he's beans have about half the caffeine of the dark roast you get from like a
Starbucks or somewhere.
They're not
high caffeine beans.
The beans that you have a light roast to meet him get yours is,
and so is that better than a dark road is?
Yeah.
And it turns out the darker you go,
the less antioxidants you have.
And the more,
uh,
acrylamides that if for acrylamide,
I'm one of the chemicals PCA that it forms.
And what about as far as the other neuro enhancers of coffee in the fat working
synergistically to have that available to our brains.
What you want to do is turn off inflammation in the brain because when your
nerves are inflamed,
they conduct electricity faster.
So you want to think faster.
You want to basically do everything you can to turn down inflammation.
So what I figured out was if you brew your coffee the way your burn it with a
French Press,
that preserves the coffee oils and the coffee oils contain die turpines.
They're called Kaphas strong cow hall.
And what these things do is they go into the brain and they turn off certain
inflammation pathways.
This is true of any kind of coffee.
How's that?
So if you take my coffee,
which has no mycotoxins and no histamines in it because of the way it's
processed,
the bulletproof process,
and then you brew it right the way you just did before the show and the French
Press,
then what you're getting is these coffee oils that are kind of precious.
They're one of the things that make coffee and do a legitimate super food.
And then you mix it with these other fats and they get into the body while when
the other fats you're getting from bulletproof coffee is butyric acid in that
butter,
short chain fatty acids there.
Those things actually heal the gut,
which is kind of cool.
There's only two ways you can get them if you're lucky and you have the right
bacteria growing in your gut,
which a lot of people don't.
You may make those in your gut,
but the other place to come from is from dairy,
so you're getting something that turns off inflammation in the brain,
which is what short chain fatty acids do and it heals your gut,
which is kind of cool and that's just water.
That's my butter's a good food.
No.
People were skeptical about your claims that it's Mycotoxins,
that it's in coffee,
that is what's causing discomfort and the crash and all that stuff.
Has that been proven?
Is there like a test or a study that you can show that shows that mycotoxins are
at x level?
I'm in the very late stages of publishing an IRB approved study of upgraded
Coffee Institutional Review Board.
It's like a legitimate medical kind of study.
I did it go and I start wondering,
you could just run it through us.
I don't think that you guys are being
taped,
but so now I'm working with a guy from Stanford University or are there,
you actually works at Google too and we tested your cognitive function on my
beans versus major beans,
like major normal ones and the difference on what was it,
six of nine measures of cognitive function was very substantially different on
upgraded coffee is that it's the mycotoxins.
It's also sometimes the histamine depending on,
but have you tried,
have you done tests on various brands?
You could show the mycotoxin levels of these brands?
I haven't conducted those tests but I don't need to because it's a known
industry problem and there's tons of stuff I referenced on this site and most of
those don't come from coffee roasters.
Coffee roasters pissed off when I say it,
it's like if there was mold on my beans,
I would see it
and my guys,
they have a gay voice.
Have you been in one of those coffee places?
That's just how it intelligentsia.
But hold on a second.
I've got it.
I've got to disagree with you.
I don't know whether or not your beans have more or less mycotoxins.
I don't have my own lab,
but yeah,
I have to.
I do know is if you,
if you say your stuff contains no mycotoxins are less mycotoxins,
you should test the other stuff and say what it contains so you can show the
difference.
So that's a,
that's a fair question.
I don't think you should even try to say that they have it until you do that.
Okay.
If,
if a university has done the study and they've done a study with like thousands
of samples all over the place or hundreds of samples depending on which study
and they've done them for 20 years,
I'm just citing those studies because I don't have enough money to conduct all
those studies has been done.
Yeah,
it's been done for the past 40 years,
40 years.
What has the process of,
um,
how they,
how they roast coffee changed since then or how they clean it?
It's actually,
yeah,
actually neither are roasting thing or even really a cleaning thing.
What happens is a bug comes in,
it bites the coffee,
and we've done studies on the bugs.
We know 50% of the bugs that Bite Coffee Cherries have toxic mold spores on
their feet and that that's how the toxic molds enter this the chain.
This means if you pick the right coffee and you have someone who's trained at
picking unblemished coffee,
that coffee has not been inoculated with the bad stuff,
but then if you're doing like an Indonesian or an African process,
you literally pick all the coffee,
including the stuff that has bird bites and insect bites and everything else
that are ways for this mold to get in there.
You throw it on a tarp and you let it sit there.
It sits there for a while until it basically spoils and the outside dries up and
then you rinse it off,
dry it again and ship it off.
The other way they do it as they put it in a big bucket or a big barrel.
They add water and let it sit for a day or two and it spoils again.
The outside of the coffee chair gets all like slimy work to spoil except with
mine.
Mine's mechanically processed oil mean.
When you say spoiled
person in the world,
who does this?
The whole bulletproof process.
I invented the bulletproof process.
I'm the only one that that's done every step of the chain and optimize it that
way.
What is getting done to your coffee beans?
So done.
Anybody else's,
so it,
well,
some of it,
I'll tell you,
there's a couple of steps that are proprietary.
I'm not going to tell you the rest of the steps are that I allowed zero
fermentation during the processing of the coffee.
So people,
folks out of my roast,
I have a micro roast.
I love coffee roasters,
but if you put beans that have problems in the toxins I'm talking about are heat
stable.
This is such a problem that in Europe they have a a safe,
acceptable level for Okra toxin in coffee.
It is not set in the u s so if you go to Europe and you drink coffee,
they have to test their coffee.
They've changed the whole coffee industry in Europe,
the level of Okra toxin and is eight parts per million.
And if you sell coffee that's above that in Europe,
you're not even allowed to do that.
In the U s there is no limit.
So where do you think the cheap coffee goes?
It has to go to the u s and I love coffee.
I am a coffee person.
So when coffee people who have the most expensive,
high tech,
amazing roasters,
and they spent their life studying coffee and they're getting beans that came
from this great estate,
they put them in and well,
I'm sorry,
if those things had histamine or they had mycotoxin or Okra toxin or aflatoxin
in it,
then what's going to come out of that roaster?
It might taste and smell wonderful,
but you're not going to be at optimal human performance when it's done.
So how did you find the right way to do this and how did you go about
establishing a business and you do you buy your beans roasted from a company
that you know,
handles it in a certain way?
I know of a bug just doesn't land on something though to awesome.
It's okay if a bug lens on it because I allow no fermentation.
So the problem is number one inoculation,
which comes from bugs.
Number two is fermentation,
which takes whatever landed on there from the bugs.
So I've got steps like,
like the guys who pick the coffee have to be able to pick beans that are
actually ripe.
And the annoying thing about coffee is that on the same branch,
some beans are ripe,
some are not,
and they're all clustered together.
So you've got to go through and actually pick out the right ones if you do it
right.
So typical bulk commodity coffee,
they pick it with guys who just strip everything off.
You go to some Starbucks stores,
they actually have a photo of like this beautiful,
you know,
bags of beans.
Half the beans aren't right.
Yeah,
they're green and black and brown.
They're all different.
Those beans,
not someone who knows how to pick coffee.
Right?
So what's going on there?
It was cheap.
You're going to ferment them anyway.
No one's going to notice.
How did you form this company?
How did you get about changing the way it's processed?
Well,
I paid for my undergraduate studies by selling caffeine tee shirts over the
Internet.
I was the first guy to sell anything.
Ever said Caffeine,
my drug of choice with a picture of the caffeine molecule of those before.
Yeah.
I made that up.
I was like,
I was a kid and I needed to pay for my school.
I didn't like working at Baskin Robbins anymore,
so I started this little tee shirt thing and put it on using it.
It was amazing what happened and it was,
you know,
enough to pay for my school,
just barely,
so that was good.
But I had to give up coffee because I started,
I kept drinking it and I would go up and I'd crash and I go up and I'd crash.
Then it gets sore joints and it turns out I had Stacie buttress like the really
bad toxic mold living in my house and it sensitized my immune system to toxic
molds and I've done all the lab work and I can show you they're really bad toxic
black mold where they have to fumigate your whole house.
That's what the astronauts students come in and that kind of thing.
As opposed to be a mother,
fuck it will fuck you up.
Like if you have water damage in the house and you don't hire guys and
astronauts whose to come in and test it and clean it like you could,
you could die.
It's like you said that Tom like his head that he was sick for a while and they
had to go in there and and terrorist whole fucking all support.
That happened to me.
Like they had guys literally they measured it and they came back and astronauts
who it's like we're not coming in here without these and saying,
and I was in there and my immune system got sensitized,
so I'm like,
I'm like a canary.
Like you give me moldy coffee.
I'll tell you within 10 minutes if there was mold in there because it affects my
forehead swells up,
you'll see like a ridge,
like a cling on Ridge,
right?
That's I'm saying when you have moldy coffee,
seriously my forehead,
I have some photos like swells up right here.
Please send those photos to minute.
I put them on Instagram.
That's ridiculous.
So,
so I have magic coffee skills there as well as some other foods.
Right.
What did you do?
Did you start a business or did you start buying beans from a business that knew
what they were doing?
I gave up coffee first and then I just,
I finally said I'm going to break down.
I'm just going to have coffee and I didn't have any symptoms and I was so happy.
And the next day I had coffee and I had symptoms and I'm like,
so I decided I did all this research,
like tons of research.
Then I spent two years like going around saying how can I like improve the odds?
And I post on the site,
I tell you how you can find coffee that's kind of clean and that at least makes
a difference.
And then I said,
well,
I think I can make coffee this perfectly clean.
So I talked to some of the top roasters in the country and some of the top being
guys.
And I went around and I interviewed different people about how their beans were
processed.
And I explain the bulletproof process to them.
And I said,
this is the process I devised based in all my research.
Can you give me green beans like this?
Can,
can you modify your plantation operations to do this?
And they said yes.
And then I went to the top rank roaster in the u s and I said,
these are the beans.
I want you to roast them.
And then they roast them to my specs,
which are a medium roast because that's the optimal health thing.
I may end up doing a,
uh,
another roast,
a dark roast,
but this was like a multiple year thing from the company.
And then you bring them to a roaster.
I get the beans from the plantation like this.
These are the guys who grow my beans and they'd pick them my way and they
process every step.
Right now,
Central America,
I get them from,
so I have a Guatemalan supply and another couple on the online in other
countries nearby.
I'm concerned about the rust is going on down there right now.
Coffee,
fungus called rust is decimating central America right now.
They could lose 70% of their crop next year.
Like you'll probably pay a buck more for a cup of coffee a year and a half from
now because of this.
Okay,
so these people grow it for you and you,
you're insured,
they're only picking the right ones and then,
and I tested,
they roasted themselves.
No,
no.
Someone else does.
Right.
And there's a whole supply chain problem between wind coffees picked and then
how it's packed and how it's moved into the u s my roasters is in the Pacific
northwest,
so they do my roasting for me and then I shipped straight from there.
It's a moldy ass place.
The Pacific northwest seemed like the worst place to get rid of bold.
It's a fair point actually.
I should do in Phoenix.
Yeah.
There you go.
Um,
so now you,
you get it,
you roasted.
Do you have like a roasted by date that you put on the baggage?
You know I I that is the end.
The plans right now,
the stuff never sits in the warehouse for like more than a week.
How long can I keep it in my cupboard or freezer or it'll be safe for six plus
months.
You're totally fine there,
but it'll be most flavorful if you get it in the first month,
which is what we'd like.
What if I freeze it?
Is that got any benefit at all?
Freezing has benefits.
Here's what I would,
I do if I want to freeze it is I take a little vacuum packer thing and I sucked
the air out of it.
If you don't have a vacuum pack or you could just suck the air out,
there's a little valve,
that little valve we use the expensive valve,
not the cheap ones that lets the CO2 out.
Cause when you roast beans,
you put them in a bag,
they produced their own carbon dioxide and that can like puff up the bag.
So you need to let that pressure out.
So he just,
you suck the air out,
you can just go,
just suck it as far out.
I have a little machine that does that and put a piece of scotch tape over it
and toss it in the freezer and that's going to store really,
really well.
And here's where people go wrong when they freeze their coffee.
If you take it out of the freezer,
you cannot open that bag until it's room temperature.
Cause you know like like a glass,
we'll get frosty.
Oh the last thing you want is water getting on your roasted coffee cause it'll
ruin the flavor for sure.
So what you do then is you just take it out,
you let it sit there and the next morning you cut the bag open and you're going
to have really fresh,
really good coffee.
So a lot of people buy my five pound bags.
They take those and they like put half of it into a,
uh,
one of those like Costco vacuum seal things and they just toss it in the
freezer.
And that's the most economic way to do it.
And if you put in the freezer,
how long is it good for like the uh,
it's good.
I've never measured the total length.
Probably depends on freezer burn and whatever else is in there.
But a long time,
like as long as meat would be good,
the Internet is a ruthlessly critical place.
So I know you get fucked with a lot.
A lot of these ideas,
the,
you know,
people claim that they were unsubstantiated and there's no,
yeah,
it's kind of funny.
What does,
what does the European Union and have an eight parts per million Okra toxin and
the US doesn't?
Well,
there's other,
there's other things that I've read that show that there's absolutely an issue
with mycotoxins and all sorts of food and the apples apparently and Hatchell in
is what grows in an apples or the toxin that comes into apples.
And when you hear stories about like Tom Laqueur's,
his house getting,
I mean that's a poison fungus.
That's horrible house.
Yeah,
this is a real issue and all sorts of different things,
isn't it?
It's actually really scary because our bodies work pretty well.
If you eat something that's really spoiled,
like you'll,
you'll throw up and you'll get sick and then you'll recover.
And if you were growing your own food or you were a caveman,
then okay fine.
The next day you eat meat that wasn't spoiled or whatever it was and you just go
on with life.
But when we have big food involved,
they're like,
oh,
here's the safe limit of these toxins.
So let's dump a truck full of tomatoes into the tomato processing plant in.
Some of them are spoiled and moldy and some aren't,
but it's okay cause we're at the low acceptable limit.
But our bodies don't like a low acceptable limit because it's like a chronic
background noise of inflammation that keeps the body inflamed.
It's not enough to make you sick to make you throw up,
but it might be enough to make you tired to make you flip the guy off and
traffic in front of you to feel agitated and aggressive.
So what I found,
trust me,
I don't like this.
I would love to just go to Mcdonald's and get like really healthy food that
makes me feel good that doesn't do that.
But I found if I want it to be,
you're bulletproof.
I want to be at that point where my brain worked and I had all the focus and all
the energy I wanted and I didn't get fat like I used to be when I weighed 300
pounds.
He must have surely changed other things as well though.
It's not just mycotoxins,
like it's 70% of my calories from healthy fats.
Mostly saturated.
Like,
I mean I,
I've optimized every single thing I can,
but like,
I mean you guys are both in better shape than I am,
but I work out 45 minutes a month.
I do my whole body vibration 45 minutes a month.
I'm not kidding.
I do high end,
not a minute.
Less ridiculous.
That's five times more than me.
Really busy.
I mean,
I,
I'll stand on my,
my,
my vibration plate.
I do that more often than how dare you think?
That's a workout and it's awesome.
I have one.
I,
you tend to,
we,
it's probably more healthy.
That's incredible.
You work out 45 minutes a month.
It's like I lift some heavy things every now and then basically.
And I do it for very short periods of time.
Just in your cardio.
Just turned a dog.
Shit never tests.
It never does.
I got to walk up to my car.
What do you mean for real?
I mean,
now what do you know?
What about nicotine?
But hold on,
let's talk about this.
He's still working out 45 fucking minutes a month to can't just gloss over that.
I'm a solid dude,
right?
I'm not like assault.
As you guys know,
you are given that five minutes a month.
So do you have a day that you pick?
Once a month we'd just go fucking crazy and lift a shitload of things for 15
minutes.
Maybe 15 minutes,
three 15
every day,
three times every month.
And so what?
I'm not that religious about it.
It's like barely once a week or not really.
If I'm home and I've got access to my vibration plate,
which amplifies the effects,
I'll stand there with the Kettlebell.
Hold the Kettlebell like this for five minutes vibrating 30 times a second,
but that's what you call a workout.
Amazing.
That's ridiculous.
But here's what you need to get.
You need to get into a Goddamn Jiu Jitsu class.
I really,
I really want to get into that.
We'll kick that 45 minutes a month.
Right?
They're everywhere now.
They used to be,
they weren't everywhere.
You had to be to get behind those 45 minutes.
I'm at Shit.
You know what?
I'm actually a yellow belt in judo.
I'll tell you.
Are you really?
Yeah.
When did he do it?
12 here's the problem.
I live in a small town and I'm on airplanes 150 days a year,
so I,
I actually miss even go to yoga class.
It's like I'm a pretty accomplished yoga.
I can put my ankles behind my head and all that rocks Twitter page.
We'll go and look at the Twitter page of the rots at drag.
You want to get driven?
Yeah.
This fucking guy is on a plane probably as much as you,
but he's,
he posts pictures of himself at the weight room at six 30 in the morning or
whenever he lands,
whatever,
whatever time has gotten to gets it in there.
Does it say in the last three years I started the bulletproof executive.
I moved countries and I'm a senior executive at this big company.
Like I'm a vice president in that micro.
So I'm basically doing two full time jobs and I slept for two years straight,
less than five hours a night on purpose.
And if I want to work out like the level you guys do,
I got to get my sleep.
I would need three more hours of sleep too.
I mean,
it's not like,
it's not like I'm sedentary.
I'm not some comic that sleeps all fucking day.
I fucking,
I mean like I,
I'm one of the busiest people that I know.
But how much do you sleep?
Probably seven hours in a day to look like you.
So I do four to five hours a night,
right?
And so I could trade I,
if I work out more,
I got to get another couple hours sleep.
And then that's interesting.
So you feel like there's a less of a demand because you don't work out.
So you choose to use your resources another way.
And that's,
that's what I'm doing.
And a nice way of rationalizing the fact the only workout 45 minutes a month.
That's what that is.
I'm a formerly obese guy and one of the things I did is I started this
experiment,
4,000 calories a day,
five hours
or less of sleep per night and no exercise.
And I was going to try and gain like a couple pounds.
So I could say,
look,
I should have gained 20 pounds.
I gained two pounds.
I did it for two years.
I should have weighed 616 pounds at the end of that experiment.
And I weighed like a pound more than what I weighed before.
Like within,
you know,
an error margin of poop.
So I actually got more muscle mass during that time though,
which was bizarre to me.
So that put the,
what else were you doing though during that time?
During that time I was reading you submitting your testosterone's?
Yeah,
surely had some effect.
Yeah.
I keep my testosterone it basically the mid range for someone who's 30 and I had
very low testosterone because I was obese.
So my testosterone over aromatase.
As it turns to estrogen very quickly,
at least it used to,
it doesn't anymore with the way I eat and the other supplements I take.
So for me,
since since 30 I've been using small doses of bioidentical testosterone and I
put them on my armpits.
I do it once a day and I measured my blood levels.
So I've never been like above the normal levels.
I'm not like super.
Normally I'm juicing.
Not ever,
but the measuring yourself over this time period,
you said you gained muscle?
Yup.
We doing the testosterone.
Before you started that measurement,
I have to do it.
While you were doing,
I've been doing that testosterone every print.
I want to say every day cause I miss a lot of days cause I forget to smear it
on.
But I've been doing it pretty much since for the last 10 years.
So no,
then so I didn't change it.
I held a concert.
You had it?
Yeah.
Huh.
That's interesting.
I don't know why you would gain muscle mass from not working out.
That seems like I have some theories about that I was doing,
I invented bulletproof intermittent fasting during that time,
which is when you do bulletproof coffee during an intermittent fast.
I'm sorry,
but you could be a hilarious Saturday night live sketch.
If you get any more famous,
you're in trouble because we're going to do a sketch where everybody wanted to
take a bulletproof shit,
my bullet proof car and go to the bulletproof office.
You know I,
this is my bulletproof secretary.
Let's see if you're in my bubble.
I'm going to have to check you.
You ran out.
Alright,
I'll stop bulletproofing stuff Joe,
but no more.
All right,
fair enough.
It's an awesome name.
It's an awesome name,
but what do you want to call?
Just totally busting your balls.
You,
what was the word,
the term you used for?
Well,
there's intermittent fasting where you eat nothing crew.
Fascinating.
Yeah,
and so there's this new thing and I don't know what to call it.
We'll call it upgraded.
Anyway,
that's another thing.
That's another Ted Nugent thing.
Everything's an upgrade.
Oh,
is it really?
He likes to upgrade things.
I got to talk to great America upgrade this.
That's hilarious.
I had no idea who was doing that.
You gotta Watch this show.
It's a great show on television.
Let's show spirit of the wild.
I had no idea he had a television show.
Dude.
You don't even know dude.
Great.
It's fucking show ever.
It's a hunting show.
This is what Ted Nugent does every week.
He has a giant piece of land with all these animals.
Okay,
so he leaves some food out.
It's got a camera man with him.
He
leaves some food out of the deer,
goes to the food.
He shoots it with an Arrow.
It's the spirit of the why all this wild man and nature and spirit and shooting
his pets.
Just go ahead and look through his album covers and you're looking at a fucking
wild man.
Oh,
he's a white dude.
Never done any drugs ever.
Like he looks like a wild eyed acid freak from the 60s and most of the shots.
Yeah,
he's a wild hunter.
He loves hunting.
I mean,
look,
it's the way to procure food if you want all your animals in the yard and shoot
him,
it's hard to preserve.
Basically.
He has,
yeah,
he's got a game reserve,
which is I'm,
I have no problem with it at all.
I mean,
if,
if I had a problem with that and I didn't have a problem with farming,
I think that'd be incredibly grew up in Michigan and there's,
I dunno,
there's like a hundred thousand accidents that happened because of deer in the
highways every year.
If you like the DNR,
they monitored that shit closely that,
you know what I mean,
that they're on top of that.
How many animals we need to call the herd every year.
And if they're not like why disease happens to all of these or they came to Lyme
disease.
Lyme disease is a,
an east coast dude in Michigan disease up there when the deer population started
on the east coast,
when you have mild,
mild winters and they don't,
there's nothing else that's negating the herd.
They,
it gets ramp it.
And there's a bunch of different diseases like that they'll like sweep through.
There's not really a time.
Other ones.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
And you know,
people don't want to accept that.
You have to call the herd.
That's a real outfox look at our life.
We will,
you know,
live fucking human.
We've got damage driving yesterday near my house where this beautiful deer just
walking by the side of the road and I rolled down the windows and my kids are
all looking at it at my wife's looking at it.
We're like,
hey,
the deer just standing there looking at us.
But you know,
it's,
it's beautiful.
I absolutely agree with you,
with everybody that loves him.
But I'd shoot that thing and eat it too.
And it's nothing wrong with that.
Eat it.
And I would revere it.
And that's the reason why there's not many of them.
Okay.
There's a reason why I see one like only once every month or so.
It's cause there's a lot of fucking coyotes out there that eat their babies.
Yeah.
That's the number one thing.
You know,
when,
when people have coyotes near them,
they don't have any as many deer fauns cause they get those funds,
they get them when they're really young.
Coyotes are ruthless,
they're smart as hell.
They're smart as hell.
And they smell it.
They can smell.
When a female has given birth,
they can smell blood and they'll come and they'll call each other.
And they're pretty sophisticated about their hunting tactics
on ATVs with dogs running pit bulls.
And uh,
my friend's dog,
there's a coyote that's just loping around a curve of this canyon.
And,
and fucking,
it's teasing.
It
starts running after it and it's just keeping it,
it could totally take it,
keeps it within distance.
They round the corner and you hear,
you hear it go crazy.
We fucking zip over and there's fucking eight coyotes that are surrounding the,
it's like it lures them in and then they fucking kill it.
It's crazy.
They bite in the back sides where all the arteries are.
What happened when you guys showed up?
They split.
Wow.
You're fucking haunters man.
They'll eat dogs for dinner in the park.
They're in Griffith everywhere.
Dude,
I've seen on Hollywood boulevard just opened down the street.
The first time I saw one,
I'll never forget it.
I just started a,
I had an apartment that the oak woods,
woods or furnished apartments.
When I first moved here,
I didn't have my own place and I was driving into the,
uh,
it was on in Burbank and I'm about to make a turn and I look and I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
There's coyotes like walking down Burbank.
Just tricky tee,
tee,
tee.
They're creepy little claws could click clacking on the ground.
I was like,
this is fucking nuts.
But after a while,
you get totally used to it.
There's a pack that lives in my neighborhood.
I see him at least once a week.
Just make,
there's like three of them.
What do you think they sleep at night?
I think.
I think they only day in the day,
rather.
The La,
the La River's right next door.
I have like a little burrow hang out.
They dig in a little hole somewhere and they just sleep in there.
Wow.
Like their dads are always in little like little gullies off this side where
there's little,
a little bit of shade and all that.
Yeah.
They're creepy fucking animals.
A lot of people think them to others.
So beautiful.
They will eat your baby.
No cheap.
They're not nice.
They're the,
the cons of the animal kingdom.
They really creepy animals.
Coyotes are very creepy.
Killed a woman a couple of years ago.
Coyotes.
Dude.
Yeah,
there's huge 19 year old singer.
Wow.
Young girl with like a promising career.
Apparently she had some record contract and she used to go on these walks in the
woods,
you know,
calm down and his customers,
customers,
Hungary,
fucking coyote live.
There's some big animals up there.
Like,
it's not like down here but you're in.
Why don't want to say where you are but there you have bears where you live,
right?
Tory is fine.
Basically it's on an island.
It's mostly wild.
It's fucking awesome.
It's like a good standard there.
Once places incredible.
We're about to like buy some acreage and a compound.
Absolutely man.
And we call it 15 pounds.
Two cows,
several sheeps and chickens.
We're going to do it.
It's a good idea.
I've been talking about doing that forever,
about getting together with my friends,
getting some land and this just scroll around food.
Let's have some cows,
let's add some vegetables.
But I did the math.
I can definitely support two cows on them.
We started Craig's just community wise,
it's so important.
I think we started going from,
from this local co-op's and they start bringing vegetables in and yeah,
I get people together at the gym and I say,
how many guys want to go in on a car and we'll buy a local grass fed cow and
that can really supporting that industry.
Man,
I've got a hundred pounds of meat in my freezer.
We just fed off.
It comes like four bucks a pound or something instead of nothing and so much
better for you.
It's so crazy.
I'm like,
you,
you like game.
It's good dude.
It tastes very different than regular.
Got To start to vote with your dollars at a certain point when your vote doesn't
matter anywhere.
It's like it matters where I fucking spend my money there.
This thing by caught that is bringing that up.
Yeah,
and and it's,
it's,
it's like at you,
you're impotent almost as it is.
It's by caught I think B,
u y c o t,
t and a.
You can just,
yeah,
you can get it wherever on your iPhone.
I'm sure you can get it for androids also would by now,
but they're just,
and it,
you scan whatever it is and it looks up and it goes,
oh,
they support Monsanto.
They support.
Gmo Is,
they gave $500 million.
It delineates who's supporting what.
You know?
That's a great idea.
We're going to talk about salmon,
which is part of this bike,
and you really going to be able to change the way you can't do shit except with
your dollars.
And if you're not supporting local farmers pretty soon,
that's going away,
right?
They're already,
they're already suing people.
Like they're talking about taking over the corn,
the last May's that's really an in Mexico as if like,
that'll be hard to buy out a impoverished country.
Like of course they're going to take that over.
You know what I mean?
That's just the next that's happening.
So the last real corn,
what?
Was there like wild or is it like there's the farmers that are there.
All our seeds are in Mexico.
All our seeds everywhere.
Subjugated.
So even as local farmers in America,
you're going to be at the,
you're going to be at the mercy,
you're going to be growing seeds that are genetically modified seeds.
They're like,
well,
it's already too far to turn back really,
because they,
they've sued everybody else out of existence and their seeds are so prolific
that they'll go.
Then they're engineered to dominate other strains and that that's just what will
happen with all grains,
with all grown vegetables.
Eventually with salmon now they made it or not modified salmon that are on
shelves that you might've eaten unbeknownst to you.
It's really scary because the deal is if the pollen crosses into your field and
then,
exactly and what's happening in the pollen does cross in the field and then they
proved that with the,
the Supreme Court supports Monsonto in that way is that they go,
well we found this in your field.
He's like,
yeah,
cross pollinated.
It's my grain or whatever.
I used it and yeah,
they polluted my thing.
No,
no.
You're using their seeds and those seeds are trademark and you're sued out of
existence.
And then when sample it takes that one over and that's happened all across
America.
They're trying to do it in India.
India is one of the only places that has a class action lawsuit against the
independent company.
A corporation like Monsanto.
Well,
they just lost in Brazil.
Is that right?
And lost a huge settlement in Brazil.
Brazilian farmers were so compromised here,
but,
but that's the last thing I'm doing is I'm going,
well,
I just have to go local and in my community with my voice to go here.
Here's,
here's options that we have and you need to be cognizant of where you're
spending your dollars.
Interesting.
Is Cara Santa Maria who was on here?
No,
she's a former science person for the Huffington Post.
What's the,
her total title?
Brian,
uh,
visor or whatever.
I don't think she had whatever she was,
whatever the,
what was the name of it?
Whatever she was.
Yeah,
whatever scientist.
She's very smart.
She thinks that the only way people can survive on this planet with the
population that we have now is with genetically modified food.
She said she understands that Monsanto may be illegal or rather unethical and
evil,
but that genetically modified foods
are probably imperative for the survival of the race.
If you believe farming is the core of how to feed people,
you might make that argument but it doesn't account for topsoil distraction.
If the only way we're going to make people survive is by pushing agriculture out
from being a centralized activity to being a decentralized activity that has a
resilience built in.
We're doing monoculture everywhere and GMOs make that even worse.
So you genetically modify something and then a new blight that's,
that's good for that one strain that's there and you're dead.
The whole
dies.
The other issue is that we're trying to dominate the actual natural corn and the
natural non genetically modified plants by allowing their pollen to do to get
into these farmers and then suing them for it and that just by fact that there
are suing these guys for it.
The reason why they're doing that is because they're trying to dominate them and
tick
them off the market and they,
they use the reason like gangster tactics.
Beer for sure.
But the,
the problem with,
um,
the scientists lady that you just,
it,
it's,
it's almost,
it's like,
it's like that hippie thing where like in,
in,
in public schools,
they're saying,
no,
everybody wins.
You know what I mean?
If there's a race,
like everybody wins and,
right,
and they're trying to diminish and mitigate anybody from having a bad feeling
about that.
And then,
I'm sorry,
you turned 17 you get out of school,
fucking,
you find out that people lose all over the place and you also,
if everybody wins in,
in your,
in your construct,
you never get to learn that,
well maybe I suck at running,
but I'm great at the Tuba or whatever.
Nobody finds their own beauty in that.
And so you're trying to make homogenize fucking people and that's disgusting.
And loathsome at one regard.
People need to learn what that hurt and what that sting and what getting punched
in the mouth is like.
The other thing is,
is that with that,
oh,
well not every,
I hear that shit all the time.
Grass Fed isn't sustainable.
I heard that shit from a woman that's like,
well,
I'm just trying to lessen my,
uh,
my carbon footprint on the earth.
And she works for,
uh,
like some environmental agency in Maine or something.
In the meantime,
she's in fertile and gets all kinds of shit to have two kids and spent thousands
or tens of thousands of dollars.
Having a child is one of the most brutal things that you can impact the
environmental with.
I'm not saying it's bad all you mothers or whatever,
but I'm saying that if nature is not giving you that and for you to force that
and force fuck your way into the fucking,
into that kind of stream,
but be against grass fed fucking cows,
fuck yourself.
That's the hardest thing to enforce her.
Her whole thing is,
is people,
you,
they have the choice right now to eat grass fed or not.
Right.
And they go to Taco Bell.
Yeah.
So that being the case,
not showing the herd,
it's a time and the money and not like there's a guy who,
well,
what's the money issue?
Because my food costs less than anybody that's eating in any kind of,
um,
common way.
Like I can buy meat at $4 a pound.
So what do we call?
Right.
But you're buying it in bulk,
a lot of sugar and have the ability to do that yet
250 bucks for a freezer at Costco.
Yeah.
B and when,
and when titty bars are getting supported all over the place and dudes or drop
in a couple of hundred dollars in a titty bar to leave with a boner,
I'm pretty sure they could,
they could put that into a cow,
man.
It was kind of get grass fed,
you know what I mean?
And so like that whole thing,
if you're,
if you're talking about people that don't want to achieve,
it's like a guy came on and he said,
hey,
ask Dave,
he hit me up on Twitter and he goes,
ask about,
um,
at what cost do you want to optimize yourself?
And I'm like,
what's the deficits?
Like not everybody wants to get better.
Not Everybody wants high performance,
but if I'm start,
decay is real.
So the deficit is death.
The deficit is,
is that I get worse off.
And so why wouldn't I want to optimize the years that I have and prolong them if
I can do it and mitigate any of the,
the detrimental.
Yeah.
So genetically modified foods are bad.
MMM.
She was wrong.
Well,
I think that she is shortsighted and a lot of my career has actually been
designing green.
That's what she's advocating.
There you go.
That's over nature.
Is that what just seems like about,
it seems like wanting to believe in science over nature when there's all these
natural foods that are already here that acts like a healthy and sustainable and
resilient.
And I built resilient systems like cloud computing for living for many years.
And one of the things you do is you make things a little bit different so that
if a hacker gets these ones,
they can't get these ones.
So what we're doing with potatoes and corn and soybeans is we're just
monocropping.
So all it takes is one thing and they're all gone.
We've gotten rid of like three quarters of the domesticated species that we used
to work with in terms of seats.
They're just gone.
We don't have him anymore.
And it used to be that,
you know,
there's a thousand varieties of potatoes that's insane and it's just
unconscionable.
It's got to stop
you talk about what the unknown things are there in the rain forest that are
getting cut down.
Like all the different plants that we have that we haven't even classified yet
that are being destroyed on a daily basis.
Like there's so much shit on this earth that we don't even know him.
And for the arrogance to come in and say,
we need to homogenize all grains,
meats,
and everything so that we can feed a whole population in 20 years from now at
the rate that we're growing and expanding.
That's so ridiculous.
And it's such an arrogant viewpoint.
It,
it's coming from such a place of scarcity also.
It's like even consciously in my own life,
talking about people,
uh,
and,
and what changes are and,
and as long as I'm going,
I need more.
I need this,
I need that.
I need more money or whatever.
When I'm thinking of that way as a kid,
it's like there's never enough,
but when I go,
I need to make my boss some more money.
Like I need to make this business run better.
When I did that,
fucking things grew for me crazy exponentially.
Uh,
somebody was giving me a ride to the airport from the airport the other day and
they're like,
oh,
well these,
these podcasts that you do,
or when you go and speak at schools,
Tate,
or when you run this or like,
does that stuff giving you money?
And I'm like,
well,
not in a conventional sense,
but I guess existentially perhaps.
But the thing is,
is like,
I don't want anybody that's after money.
I want people that are after a revolution.
I want people that are after a whole movement that's moving in a positive,
progressive manner.
You know what I mean?
And,
and,
and that stuff would,
that homogenization of America or of the world is not,
it's just creating more borders and,
and like David said,
if there's a strain that comes up,
then that is fucking wiped out.
And now what,
because I was so arrogant to think that there was scarcity and that I needed to
control this and get my grips on it.
It's like,
it's crazy.
Go stand by the ocean and you ain't shit.
You know what I mean?
We're all moving in a whole different way.
It's a revolution against being mediocre because here's the thing about this.
How dare you,
at what costs optimize.
You're going to live your whole life being mediocre when you could have been
awesome and great.
Isn't that a much bigger waist than what it's like spitting in the face of God.
Whatever you believe in.
It's like,
so you're,
you've just okay with not not succeeding and with not showing anybody else
behind you how to get better.
It's like when you,
when you go on rants and you're talking about,
you know,
you've got a bunch of mediocre people that have mediocre kids and everybody's
mimicking that don't have a responsibility,
not only for like whether it's for my fitness or to protect somebody weaker than
me or whatever it is,
but to be the best that I can be so that you can show the next generation.
So it's like when Jesse Owens runs and he's the fastest man in the world and
tell people,
see that they go,
that's the fastest Ma.
And then the next year,
what somebody is faster.
And now with the Internet and the progressiveness of all of this,
with these ideas,
it's crazy to think that I would be anything except optimized like ridiculous.
I have Koi says you owe it to the world to kick ass.
And if you're not doing that,
it's not even about doing it for yourself.
It's you owe that to your community.
Do a shit for the world.
We show my community [inaudible] call bullshit on that.
I'm getting up and going to the gym for the community.
I'm not,
I'm a grown ass man.
Pull Shit Shit for me to sell through and sift for yourself.
But you owe it to them.
I don't know.
Well,
you know I'm fucking around.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Realistically,
you know,
Oh shit.
I said Buck.
I think that the idea that there's a separation between us and that is that is
the thing and I know you know it's bullshit too.
It's like it's like if we're all vibrating at a higher level of consciousness
that is in sync with whatever the universal vibration is,
the more pot that there's not hiccups in the gears.
You know what I mean?
And,
and there's not like,
it's that illusion of separation that keeps us all in this fucking muted state
of consciousness that creates road rage that creates like the idea that I need
to control the ocean or the fucking crops or whatever.
Meditation is so important because when you start,
you start feeling all that stuff,
you realize that you're not as a separate,
I'm thinking
people need to hear from people like yourself or either one of you who have
experience ups and downs and have some idea of what it's changed in their life
that's been beneficial.
And that way a person listening can learn without having to go through and the
mistakes that I or you might've made.
So huge.
It's huge.
It's very important.
It's unfair that I had to spend $300,000 and then
I could spend $300,000 on all the stuff.
So that right now like that it's,
it's,
it's incredible.
I mean the,
the,
the change that that's made and then that the Internet's made and,
and Joe,
like,
like I would have never started a podcast without like you go and dude,
you've got to,
you've got to make people privy to whatever conversations and madness and
enlightenment.
And then I thought too,
man,
when I was talking to coach the,
a couple of weeks ago,
I did one with Mr Greg Jackson.
There was fantastic.
And,
and I would have never maybe seen Greg again or see him in passing,
but to go and set aside time for conversations with people that you admire and
that you revere and that you're like,
oh,
this is like fuck what a opportunity that is.
And you get to put it out there so other people can experience it too.
So these people that had been so formative in your life,
right?
Yeah.
We're getting people that you meet and talk to.
Um,
I don't know where we were when we went on this,
this little turn until illness,
but um,
yeah,
the idea that we could do a better job than nature itself.
The idea that a Monsanto owning life forms is a good idea.
There's a couple of patent plan.
It's worse than mine.
What's the Monsanto cause they own you.
Yeah,
because right,
right now the human genome is essentially all patented,
right?
Yeah.
Well remember when they,
there was a guy,
there's a guy last year that got charged with,
uh,
by the DEA with transporting drugs because he was saying there's,
there's a thing in boulder or somewhere like that where you can do stem cell
shit and they're saying you're taking your own body across state lines.
That's a fucking federal crime because you're going with the intention of taking
your stem cells out.
That's a controlled substance,
right?
That's a drug.
And so they fucking charged this poor cock sucker with transporting illegal
drugs across state lines because they want to stop that fucking yeah.
Progress and get this like Angelina Jolie,
you know,
she,
she had her breasts amputated because she was afraid she might get cancer.
Now there's a lot about epigenetics,
a lot of research I've done there about how your environment affects your cancer
risk.
And I'm sure she'd thought she was doing the right thing.
But here's the thing.
The company that does the test for Brc one and two,
the jeans that she has that put her at high risk,
they own those jeans.
They patented them.
They can restrict anyone else from doing research on those genes,
even to prove that those genes don't do anything.
What I'm not joking.
The company does that.
They make like $1 billion a year that's off breast cancer genes and no one else
is allowed there unless they say so because they own the gene.
They make $1 billion a year off breast cancer genes off the tests for four to
$5,000 to test you for this BRC hygiene that they've identified.
They own the testing that they own,
the use of that gene.
And here's the thing,
I sequenced my whole human genome on 23 and me,
it's 99 bucks,
right?
So why is it that the machines have gone down in price,
but it's so expensive?
It's because they have a monopoly on it.
It's patented.
So there's a huge percentage of the human genome is patented and basically owned
by companies and it's only owned because the supreme court said,
so are you,
it's got to stop.
Are you bullshit on the numbers of people that will get breast cancer because
they have this gene?
Do you think that that is something that they have put out there to get people
to test for it?
I think that there is a risk associated with the gene,
but that the environmental risk trumps that.
If that's the core of epigenetics,
that's the core of my whole book here.
It's the environment controls what genes get methylated and methylation is
basically when RNA comes into copy DNA,
it has to be able to methylate things and the environment controls what the RNA
can copy.
Environment meaning specific chemicals in the air or environment,
meaning chemical weapons,
love relationships,
all of it.
So how stressed are you filled?
How stressed are you?
So in fact,
the main pillars in the safety for making like optimize children who like have
every opportunity you can give them,
you need to control your own stress.
The light you're exposed to is part of your environment.
The smog gear exposed to everything goes in and changes your,
your genes and it changes the amount of very frequent basis.
And how exactly does that work for the lay person who doesn't understand genes?
How does it change your genes?
You Imagine?
There's like a firewall around your DNA and your DNA stores,
the set of things,
your potential.
So there's a firewall and your RNA comes into copy.
That DNA when it tries to come in and copy of the DNA,
it can only copy what it can get past the firewall to see.
And the firewall is configured by the environment.
So it turns out you're exposome the set of everything you're exposed to,
your emotions,
your pollution,
your toxins.
When you exercise,
when you sleep,
the quality of your sleep,
everything that changes these things.
So you might have a statistically higher chance of getting breast cancer from
BRC one or BRC too.
But can you account for that by going to sleep earlier by eating things that
don't contribute to cancer?
Like what are the environmental things you can do to balance risk?
So what Angelina Jolie did as she ignored the thing she could do to balance
risk.
As far as we can tell,
I don't know Angelina Jolie,
I've never met her,
but she went ahead and made this relatively drastic decision.
Like,
I can tell you there's x amount of chance of me getting armed cancer,
but I'm not cutting off my arms.
Right.
And seriously the line of thinking,
it says you amputate things that might get sick instead of monitoring them and
doing everything in your power to keep them from getting sick.
That seems broken.
There's a,
there's a school of thought on some forms of cancer that were like,
some families just have some on avoidable form of cancer.
I mean
she got breast implants and that was the thing that she put out to the press.
She says,
I did this as a precautionary thing because everybody in my family got breast
cancer and I was like,
whatever reason you did it for awesome.
Did she really say that that was her?
That was her press.
She was probably afraid of judgment of the,
you know,
all you're trying to augment yourself in this regard or that regard.
And so she said you,
I was like,
that's legit man.
Whatever the reason.
So there's a whole class of cancers that,
that form after you're injured,
so where there's like a scar or an abrasion.
So even the act of doing a breast removal creates another risk factor for
cancer.
And what's the risk of having a micro stroke under surgery?
It's like between two and 5%.
Like it's not a risk free thing.
I just feel like there's huge amounts of fear for some things when the rest of
the body,
yeah,
you like,
you altered the body and you know,
like in a way like all surgeons will say that they're like,
if you can avoid surgery at any cost,
please do that because we all through your body,
all the Fascia,
that is one piece that covers everything in your graph infection.
I was just talking to Bob Cook and he was telling me about a staph infection he
got from his scratch.
All of a sudden it's fucking,
I think it was his elbow blew up like crazy and he took drugs right away.
Wasn't good enough.
I've had to go to the hospital.
Those strains are changing too,
and they're getting more and more resilient or more resistant to whatever
antibiotic bacteria as you can get.
But then also at have you think when you think about like,
uh,
the,
the cellular regeneration that happens with cancer and an abnormal form,
that shit is completely fed by sugars and so like that that having a low fat
diet is really harmful and a lot of different,
there's a lot of good evidence to eat and certain ways healthy fats,
low shot and sugar is bad.
Sugar actually control your insulin.
You can control,
you can mitigate a lot of cancer.
Cancer has 28
times more insulin receptors on it than a normal cell in the body.
So that means when you eat sugar,
you're basically feeding the cancer in your body.
In fact,
there's a kind of,
your cells don't want to proliferate if,
if there's not a lot of sugar and excess,
if there's a lot of sugar,
they'll go crazy.
There's not cancer.
We had a speaker at a Silicon Valley Health Institute come in and talk about
insulin.
Potentiated chemotherapy.
They take chemo drugs at like 10% of the normal concentration and they inject
them into you with insulin.
And the cancer cells love insulin so much that they just soak up the poison and
the rest of you doesn't crazy that that's how powerful sugar is.
So if you're at high risk for breast cancer,
you ought not to eat polyunsaturated oils and you ought not to eat sugar,
especially fructose.
If you do that.
How do we know what percentage reduction you have?
So if you have an 87% increased risk or an 87% risk and it tired,
no one's tested what that,
what that looks like when you take these other lifestyle things,
and if you did that right,
maybe then you monitor and you decide based on your progress,
whether you're going to have a surgery,
you're not going to have it,
but to just kind of reactively do it because of the results of one proprietary
gene test.
To me it seems kind of scary and the fact that this company owns those genes,
so I'm not allowed to do my own research on them.
I'm not allowed to have a university research on it.
You're not doing any research.
So I don't know whether you're telling the truth or not about that,
but if that is absolutely right and correct,
it's fucking crazy.
I hope I'm wrong,
but I'm not a little kid.
You look at the idea that Monsanto can patent different plants and that they in
fact tried to patent different parts from it.
It's not meant Santo that owns the human genome.
I forgot the name of the company or something.
But anyway,
visa vi the fact that your stem cells are a controlled substance,
that you can be sued for walking your body around if you have the intention of
doing that testing.
That's a non John Ashcroft nonsense that happened about a year ago.
It happened
a year and a half ago.
Really?
But,
but then the fact that if like this,
people owning owning genes are all that tea,
is it outlandish than to think that I wouldn't want to create an illness if I
had stops say in,
in this,
uh,
big Pharma Company in,
in this grain manufacturer.
I mean,
fuck man,
I want to create the PR.
Like it's like Halliburton.
It's like,
of course you want BP to fucking blow itself up in the Gulf because you're the
only one that's saying,
I can clean this up even if you can't,
whatever,
and I'm going to fleece the taxpayers.
It's all how can I fucking coopt to make as much money and doubled down on this
as I can and I'm going to buy tragedies and that's what American corporations
are doing.
I don't know.
People are making diseases,
but I know if he gave some of the opportunity to make a disease that would kill
a few week people make you $1 billion.
A lot of companies,
we'd be down for it.
They will figure out a way to legally make it happen.
That's called diabetes type two diabetes onset diabetes.
How about cigarettes?
I want the exact figure.
Exactly,
exactly.
Who knows?
400,000 plus every year in this country,
the history of the pharmaceutical and chemical companies,
you know where they all came from,
right?
Oil companies,
you go back a hundred years to like the Chrysler Chemical Company.
They came right out of the oil.
So oil first,
then oil split into chemicals and pharmaceuticals and these are like the old
historical roots.
So companies like Bayer out there that came straight out of oil and chemistry.
So they split it into making chemicals.
They split into making a drugs,
chemicals make us sick,
drugs make you well,
and it's kind of a virtuous cycle.
I'm not saying that these,
that there's a conspiracy and that you know these,
these companies are trading stuff back and forth.
It's an emergent behavior.
Most people actually aren't evil and most people aren't going to kill someone
sitting across from them or even poison a whole country to make money.
If you evil people will.
But the problem is when you make a whole bunch of small decisions to optimize
profit,
you end up with like the American healthcare system,
which is more expensive than any other country and produces suboptimal results.
It's not because there's some evil puppet master,
it's just cause overtime everyone optimize every micro decision in order to get
the most profit instead of the most human wellness.
And when you do that,
you end up with mediocrity.
And that's what we're trying to start a revolution against.
Your needs to be some complete total transparency as far as what people's
actions in terms of companies and corporations and how that affects human
beings.
That should be the bottom line.
That should be the true bottom line.
And then we'd look at a profit even they should be like a real honest and
accurate account.
If your laptop costs you $50 less than it would if people weren't jumping off
roofs,
you know,
maybe,
maybe they should set it up so you've to pay 50 bucks more for your fucking lie
or they make lip $50 less per lap.
One of the problems I think with the health care industry and,
and I don't fucking know shit.
I mean I,
I'm this side of not needing velcro shoes to fucking walk around and I got it.
Oh shoes or the shit,
he really didn't get the respect they deserve,
but far better than laces.
The whole,
the whole idea is that,
that we're basing it on the assumption that you're a broken bean that's coming
to a doctor and looking for wellness instead of that.
You come from a perfect
wellness and,
and your and,
and how to restore that state.
We're looking to do,
like I've got a friend that's been trying to get off Paxil for three years now
and every time he goes into the darkest fucking holes and he'll,
he'll forget parts of his days,
there'll be an a walking blackout.
Like how do you do that?
You're gonna have to wean yourself off of that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But even then,
man,
when he's off,
it's one of the more serious SSRI is I guess.
And it's like,
it's coming from,
from that kind of thing of you're broken and how to get you well.
And they're like,
well,
maybe you just need to be on it forever.
And it's like,
man,
that's a fucked up proposition when I go.
So I've just came,
came into this life broke and her like,
why is it now that there's 80 inoculations,
why,
why is it such a pronounced [inaudible]
autism?
Why is that such a pronounced disease right now the town,
so the autism tends to be,
males are having babies much later in life.
That's what they've directly attributed to it.
When you guys are in their late forties and they're pumping out kids,
it's very likely that that kid is going to have some issues.
We have a whole chapter in here about what's now late forties late.
It's,
I think,
I mean,
not very likely I should say.
It's like,
you know,
whatever low percentage,
but it's any much higher than it is when you're 20 or when you third age matters
a lot.
And that was how much drinking,
I mean,
you,
you may seem and you mix from like on a regular basis every three or four days.
So what,
you know,
were you drunk actually matters.
Yeah.
You could fuck up your loads.
Well said,
man.
How Sad.
Brian?
Yes.
That healthy load still don't hear nothing.
You just said that.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's,
it's a fascinating thing.
You know,
the development of human beings just not really been,
um,
accurately assessed or a really a diagrammed.
It hasn't been really engineered in a conscientious objective and really
positive way.
We've looked at what is the best way to optimize being a human being on this
planet from the way you think about things,
to how do you behave and what kind of food you put into your body.
It's really difficult to acquire this kind of information.
Yeah,
I remember writing a lot with you and go on,
Jesus can imagine being on this slave ship everyday,
talking about driving on the four oh five every day at 9:00 AM or whatever it
was.
And it's like those kinds of things I was looking at like every,
every industry that I've been in,
in my adult life,
which has been pretty much to try to not have a job.
And uh,
and I've been pretty good at it,
but having a job without having one and like I've got like a concrete cowboy is
a,
uh,
a nightclub in Dallas and one of the managers is there.
He's like,
you know,
all we're doing is the people that are working Monday through Friday,
this is what it is.
Like,
I can't wait to get out into,
and you're,
you're causing a distraction.
You're causing an illusion for them to enjoy their life.
And the next Monday and Tuesday,
that's what they're talking about is what a great time they had by Wednesday and
Thursday.
I can't wait until I do this again and recreate this,
uh,
in,
in my,
in my gym,
in Santa Fe.
It's the same kind of thing in a healthy way of like,
how can I reduce stress?
How can I enhance lifts?
How can I learn how to strangle people better?
It's like people are getting different skill sets in that,
in that way,
everything
is like how to avoid the life that I have to have so that I could have another
life kind of thing.
Or,
or making films is the same way.
I mean,
that's the only film,
the film industry,
I think in the Great Depression was the only thing that remained static or maybe
went up because people are trying to avoid the horrific fucking existence that
they're having.
And so how was it that instead of having a life that I want to escape,
I can build in a life that is satisfactory and that I can affect your health?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
You ever meet a guy who just likes to make knives?
Right?
That guy's a happy mother fucker do it.
And that's what it is.
Whatever it is that turns you on,
fucking do that thing,
man.
Yes.
That's really fucking hard to do though.
Difficult for [inaudible].
Uh,
to get to that,
that state.
So I get some news on the human genome.
Every part of the human genome sequenced by the human genome project was made
public immediately.
In fact,
a new date on the human genome was posted every 24 hours.
And it is true that some private companies that filed thousands of patents on
Human Julie's over the past several years,
it says,
we don't know how many such patents have been filed,
whether the patents will be awarded or if they're enforceable.
Most of the patent applications have not been acted upon.
So we really don't know how much,
if any of the genome can be used freely for commercial purposes.
It's a dude named Iste.
He'd van from the message board posts that.
So the company that owns Brc one and two,
those as far as I understand,
those patents are legit and that they've been accepted and they also own the
testing for that.
Yep.
So no one else can test for it even though it's like of genes there,
I can't talk about it being there and it's because they own the genes that in
owning the testing they stopped anybody from competing with them and also
testing for the jeans.
Yeah.
So if anyone else wants to do a report that says you have the BRC when she,
and they can't say that,
what about if someone wants to do research on the gene?
Can't do it.
You can't do research on the gene of the corner of the stuff I read.
Wow.
If that is true,
that is pretty fucking bonkers.
That's nuts that people would let humanity trumped by the bottom.
Bottom line.
Cause a revolution like you'll be able to sequence your own genes in your own
house and not that much longer.
You look at Moore's law,
how fast the price of this done.
Early in my career I was with this program called double twist.
There were a customer,
there's big data's when I worked for,
we had a whole floor of a skyscraper in Oakland and it was just packed with
these million dollar servers to sequence the human genome and to make it go
online and now for $99 I can get that same thing done for my DNA and this isn't,
I'm still alive like this only happened over the last 15 maybe 18 years.
That's incredible.
So you've go forward another 10 or 20 years,
you know what?
Screw these companies,
it's all going to be open source.
It has to be,
otherwise they're going to own us
trying.
Right now it's almost like the last ditch effort at the end of this weird
digital age w before we progress to the next state,
people are still trying to click on to really shitty thinking and and
corruption.
This strikes me as corruption.
It's all corruption.
It really is the,
the fact that then only these laws could have been allowed to take place that
you could have ever allowed anybody to patent a life form its own a life form
that's sue people else for also having the seeds,
that life form.
When you notice that cross pollination that's just straight evil.
No sane person would ever do it.
But companies,
they're insane.
They're not saying people.
I'm being um,
on a regular basis,
uh,
shocked by how transparent like some of these things are.
How transparent the connection between Monsanto and,
and money and influencing politicians and different things that are getting
snuck through congress.
And then you,
you,
you're hearing about these,
the Monsanto Protection Act or supposedly whatever it's called when people are
calling the Monsanto Protection Act.
And it just,
it just,
it's,
it's so gross to see like corruption so obvious.
It's so,
it's so gross to see a group of people that are supposedly are leaders that have
virtually no inspirational things to say whatsoever.
There's not a single one.
Whoever gets up and says,
what we need to do is eat healthy food,
drink a lot of water,
get a lot of exercise and meditate and follow your passion.
You need to surround yourself with good people and be good to those.
Yeah.
Or like monitor the news in a different way.
Like,
why,
why isn't that looked at like,
let's get actual news instead of fear tactics.
Yeah.
I don't watch the news anyway.
Figure 10 plus years.
If someone's going to figure out a way to make money from telling you the truth,
okay.
We can make the same kind of money.
If CNN can make more money by being honest with you,
than they could about being country and bullshitting and having Anderson Coover
in front of a green screen.
You know,
may,
maybe we would trust them.
Maybe.
Maybe you could actually make money.
That was,
I was listening to some tapes or Ronald Reagan after the like,
uh,
like he was like,
well,
it was the whole thing.
We don't,
um,
we don't negotiate with terrorists talk that he's given.
And he's saying,
we totally didn't do that.
And there's,
there was no,
uh,
there's no lesson,
but like we didn't have any kind of,
uh,
interactions with them where there was a arms for hostages type of thing and
talking about when he took over and it says one month later,
I know I said that once,
I believe in my heart that it wasn't true,
but it turns out that the facts are different than what my heart would like to
believe or some,
it sounds crazy,
but you see that happen with Obama's talk about Nda in the same speech.
There's not a month apart.
It's like in today's Day and age,
Reagan would have just never,
he would have never thought about that first speech.
It would have just maybe not even made,
made an issue of it.
But here Obama saying this is totally bad.
We'll never do any of these things,
but uh,
uh,
I'm going to sign it in any way.
Yeah,
that was the most ridiculous thing.
Probably never use it,
but we're going to sign it.
Well,
it's pretty obvious at this point that the president doesn't really get the
chance to say what goes on.
It's not one person,
right.
They're not allowing that.
It's,
it's a pretty clear.
However,
it's also pretty obvious that whoever gets to be present,
it's never going to fucking talk about it.
Bill Clinton talks about a whole lot of shit.
He doesn't talk about the Illuminati.
And so now it's what he is.
It's what he does and it adds,
it becomes more and more transparent as it becomes revealed more and more how
much of a,
a foothold,
big money,
big corporations have in,
in governments all over the world.
The more it becomes ridiculous that they don't talk about it.
So they were never really our president.
What they were,
were really good at saying the things that we really like to hear while they
were being a gangster working for the top dicks in the world.
And that's really what they did.
And that's what the one,
yeah,
your dog,
just shit,
man.
Where my smell shit,
I dunno.
I that was taped.
I wish,
right?
I said it smells like dog shit.
It doesn't sound like,
be careful what your role,
maybe she just ripped one.
She's over there sleeping.
She's right.
Oh yeah.
Geez Louise.
That's caught one of the phase.
It was definitely an animal fart.
That's rude.
By the way.
Change your dog's food.
Smells like farts.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
You think it clings to her?
Look at fog.
She smells like a beautiful little puppy.
That's right.
Um,
what do you think about,
this is one of the things that really pissed me off when I was,
uh,
learning about,
various treatments for my bulging disc issue.
Um,
there's a lot of people that are going to Europe and they're going to Europe for
treatments that aren't available in the United States because the United States
during the Bush administration had a bunch of Wacky fucking restrictions on stem
cell research.
So the Europeans got way ahead of what America is doing as far as things with
stem cells.
And a lot of professional athletes have been going over there to get these
really crazy cutting edge treatments.
I got Dana White went over there,
they pulled blood from his body,
spun it in something and they the incubates for 10 hours and they pump it back
into his body and he'd completely cured as Meniere's disease.
Yeah,
he goes back again to do it like in a few months,
but he's like,
what they're doing is like fixing people that have injuries that could never fix
before.
People with like fucked up backs.
Like Peyton manning apparently went over there and got his neck fixed.
What do you know about that shit?
I haven't done a lot of specific research on stem cells themselves.
What I do know is that a lot of the things going on with medical interventions
in the U S it's incredibly slow and hidebound.
I worked with one of the first companies that had a stick on cardiac monitor.
I designed the whole infrastructure.
Do you like get the signal off the body onto the cloud so we could analyze it
and the amount of money that that company had to raise just for compliance for
this sort of thing was incredible.
So there's all sorts of really brilliant doctors and natural paths and other
guys who have technologies that,
some of them are anticancer,
some of them are are for obesity.
Some of them are for rapid healing and in order for them to actually do it,
if they stand up and say I'm doing this,
they'll lose their license almost immediately because it's an unapproved
treatment.
So that we have this whole bureaucratic institution that forces people who are
really good healers to at least publicly support things that don't work very
well.
And they do this even though maybe at home they're doing something different
because until you have these double blind studies,
et Cetera,
it's just very slow.
So what a lot of the new groundbreaking companies,
including some of the ones that I advise,
what they do is they go overseas because if you go say to Europe or better yet
to Singapore,
you can do amazing things to heal people that are not legal to do in the u s and
might not be legal for 20 years and it will cost you a lot less money.
Like what things they have available.
You can go over there and do some of the electrical medicine,
things like that.
Electrical medicine.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
I mean my first biohacking conference earlier this year,
we had guys running,
um,
relatively heavy amounts of electrical current over the body in order to
increase myelination of the nerves.
And myelinated nerves carry electricity faster and they let you move faster.
There's,
Oh wait a minute.
You can turn people faster by electrical video.
All right.
So pretty much it's an incentive.
We had,
we had Aubrey,
they're the CEO of on it did,
he should have seen the change in his punch.
Right?
So w you made him punch harder.
Uh,
we're going to punch faster.
Pump Punch fat.
Yeah.
Cause you didn't just warmup,
no,
it wasn't that because what,
what he was doing and,
and you could see it was really dramatic effect.
I think that's in the video.
I almost have the videos done for the conference,
but um,
I'll put those online.
And um,
what,
what he was doing,
he was punching really fast,
but then his,
he was pulling back slowly.
So by running electricity and just coaching is form.
But when you learn something with the electricity going over your nerves at 500
times a second,
your mind thinks you did it 500 times that do something 10,000 times to practice
it.
That kind of effect.
Well if your mind thinks you did it 10,000 times and you only did it for a
little while,
you get the practice effect.
So I watched him before it was like fast,
slow and when he was done with this stuff after like two days of this,
he was like equally fast going on the jab and then pulling it back.
It was,
it was remarked that quicker.
He didn't punch quicker.
I don't know if you punched faster or not.
I don't think they measured that.
But you could see that they're measuring the amount of time between throwing the
punch of pulling the punch back.
Cause if you can throw three punches because you're pulling back different,
he punches however many times in 20 seconds under this and then now he's
punching this many more times than 20 seconds.
It seems like it would be something that an athlete should do right before they
did an event.
How long would it last?
And is illegal?
It's legal and the effect,
it's a nervous system.
Effects.
It's teaching the nervous system and the nerves in the body.
It's forever.
Yeah.
So essentially you could cut your amount of time that it takes to be proficient
at something by a dramatic throughout the u s military is using this in the
brain.
They use this device,
this little,
uh,
transcranial direct current stimulator thing to train drone pilots in six weeks
instead of three months.
Drone piloting is the most boring job ever.
You stare at a screen for 12 hours and if you see something that's a target,
which happens like once a day,
if you're lucky,
you press a button and then someone dies.
You're in a trailer,
they keep jacking innocent people.
Is it because they're bored and they just pull the trigger?
That's gotta be one of the hardest jobs ever.
You're killing people.
You're attending to the little video screen from an airplane.
I,
I don't,
I would not want that job to save my life.
So I got it.
I got her to stop.
She doesn't exist.
I agree.
Should be reserved for like really evil motherfuckers.
But I gotta respect the guys who are going out and doing that work cause I sure
as heck wouldn't do it but I have to take that job shouldn't exist.
It's a crazy business when 80% of the people that you kill you didn't mean to
kill and eat and you don't even know.
You don't even get to see him.
I mean the mistakes happen and I,
I get 2% of the right people.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't want that on my Karma real in person.
They say 49 people that happen to be in the cafe or whatever happened die also
and they and Obama and the military industrial complex calls that Arabian
success.
Yeah.
I heard the new update though.
You'd only kills like 20% of the people though.
That makes me feel better things.
But it's pretty amazing how we freak out about nine 11.
Don't think about what we've done so far.
Is it a drone attacks or,
well,
I mean,
you look at Boston and as fucking that's,
and that's awful and horrible,
but when I heard that it was like three people that died,
I'm like three fucking people.
That's a lot of people lost their legs.
That is the thing scattered out and blew people's legs apart.
My point being that we,
we do that in other places with innocent people everyday and we don't,
I wish we had one 10th of the iter that we had when that happened in Boston.
You know what I mean?
It's just like,
it's like just a separation of us as humans that because it happened somewhere
else,
that all of a sudden we're not responsible or accountable in some ways really.
It's also interesting how we choose to like marginalize,
modularize the numbers.
You remember when the first,
the war first started?
I don't know if you remember,
but I remember,
um,
the first deaths that were coming in,
they were telling you about the desk and the reason why they were telling you
about the desk is because our last experience with war was like the craziest
Mike Tyson first round victory ever thought Iraq is literally like,
we went over there and fucking Mike Tyson's,
you just destroyed them there.
Their whole army was gone within a couple of weeks.
And the only people that that died,
I think there was a couple that had died before,
uh,
the big accident where a Scud missile and hit a base and killed a bunch of
people that were all in one area.
And that was like the big,
that was like 79 hit somebody that was a complete accident.
Looks random.
Yeah,
I think it was,
you know,
but,
but that was,
that was the big loss.
And so I think people anticipated there was going to be the same sort of thing
again.
We'd go in there if you,
people would die.
Oh,
why can't believe they died?
But everybody was in such a nine 11 fervor.
You know there was everywhere you go,
they have American flags are hanging out on people's cars,
but then after a while they stop telling you about those people.
They just stopped,
the numbers kept piling up and they just stopped talking about it.
It wasn't like a thing where they were going to tell you every day,
three,
three marines die in Afghanistan can usually,
you'll see it a little sidebar,
but you'll see a big one about some crazy bitches stabbed her boyfriend or I see
another one about some chicken drowned her kid or you know,
or did this or left a baby in a car and they'll just dwell and follow that
person that hounded about this Zimmerman Trayvon Martin thing.
You know the divisiveness between the two races and how people are so
invested in one side or another being correct.
Fascinating Shit,
but a massive distraction in terms of the overall population of the human race.
If you look at what the Fuck Evil Shit is going on right now,
one questionable death does not merit.
I mean,
it merits people paying attention to it,
but it doesn't merit any anymore.
Then some people that die because of a drone attack that we're guilty of
anything but being poor and living in Pakistan,
those fucking people died.
Two men and they,
you know,
families and their lives and they don't even get,
there's no talk about them at all.
I mean it occasionally,
it's a number that someone will bring up,
but no one's like,
and if you do talk about it,
your label to a conspiracy theorist or a psychopath and it's like,
how has me caring about human fucking life?
What are you talking about that,
that it's like the idea that being a liberal is somehow a bad word.
It's like that.
It means free thinker.
If you study etymology of fucking words,
you dolt we wouldn't walk by,
I came,
you know,
a bad thing and on the tip all that too,
like I want to give,
you know,
Duke credence and respect and,
and,
and thanks to,
to all those people that are there that are,
that are put in an intolerable situation,
making a fucking decision.
I wouldn't want to have to make and whether it's like my friend Brian Stann
kicker,
Tommy Truex,
don Trey home,
my cousins,
Spence Fletcher,
all you guys,
everybody that's gone and served.
Thank you so much.
And uh,
and you know,
I'm,
I'm just glad I've never been in that position and,
and I,
and I respect your decision to be on the front lines there.
Cause I know that every guy that I know that ever signed up has done so with
America and those kinds of ideals of what we've been built on in America in
their hearts will
the has been propounded Tillman story when Pat Tillman went over there right
after nine 11 back.
Pat Tillman was a huge NFL star and some mother fucker.
It looks like a Barbie doll or Ken Rather.
Sorry.
I want to thank brevity Manny,
the Bradley mandates that are out there.
Got,
damn,
that's a fucking American hero.
There's a real problem with that,
huh?
It was a real problem with that.
And you take that kid and lock him in solitary confinement,
cold room with no clothes for three years.
Don't let him talk to anybody.
Yeah.
Anybody that doesn't mention his name as a hero on Memorial Day.
Well these,
none of that.
Like think of the horrible things that people have done in this country.
The horrible things that Dick Cheney probably did and the fact that
he put this kid and they locked him in solitary fucking confider for years for
releasing information about something that was clearly wrong that he felt he
needed to do.
And if you look at what actually got exposed,
well the things that got exposed,
first of all,
the names were names that were already released.
Those are the only names that they released.
But then the information itself to go exposed,
it's something that people really needed to deal with.
The really needed to deal with the attitudes that those helicopter fighter
pilots had about killing those kids that were like when they found that there
were kids in the van,
they're like,
well I should have brought their kids.
It's like,
whoa man.
Like that.
That's not what we think of when we think of America.
Right.
You know,
that shit needs to be exposed.
And if you are a true patriot,
you would be happy that that was exposed.
And if you
felt like that guy committed a crime,
maybe he needs to be prosecuted for some sort of a crime that,
but it's not what you're doing to them.
It's not locking them naked for three fucking years without getting to talk to
me.
But you tell me that it's worth than what Marie worst and what Bernie Madoff
did.
They said,
how come Bernie Madoff gets clothes and food and gets to hang a lawyer?
A lawyer gets a lawyer.
How about,
how about the gift card due to the Patriot Act and diluting the NDA,
they can infinitely detain you.
They can do,
they can detain you and definitely they can do whatever they want.
You don't have to even tell your family you're not the presidential execution
orders.
Now,
that's scary stuff.
Well,
that's the other thing with Trump's,
they've killed four people for Americans.
It's been greenlit.
Those guys like Obama's killed.
This came out through the New York Times and there's all these names on there
and they're like,
oh yeah,
these two guys that happened to die,
they,
they're American citizens that are abroad,
Bill and we murdered them,
we assassinated them.
However,
and we didn't give them due process at all,
but we didn't need to because they're off the borders.
Well then they start doing that in the United States.
You look at that fucking crazy cop that they shot like four other people that
they didn't mean to before they burned him alive in the cabin.
And you know what I mean?
It's like that seems odd that there's obviously a kill order on that guy there
he shot people that were delivering newspapers crazy that weren't even the right
color.
Color looks like ll cool j for fuck sake.
And they shoot some surfer guy and then adapt and lady,
it's like,
that seems odd.
They're just,
they're very hot about getting this guy.
I get,
I have a buddy who has friends in the intelligence business and he's like,
you know,
it was really a wake up call for a lot of people cause they're like that's a
terrible thing that happened because they had those comms shitting themselves
and it really alerted people to the fact that hey,
wouldn't be too hard to make a lot of fucking noise if one guy could do
something like that one crazy Christopher dormer met or you know,
military trained former police officer who's giant can do something like that.
What could a team of 10 guys from another country too and that are well trained
to work in unison?
It's Goddamn Chuck Norris movies,
dammit.
You better get those denim stretch jeans on,
get working.
But that,
that's the problem too with Boston is in,
in that way,
in the same way that people are like he didn't get in.
And I don't want to argue about like whether you need your brand or rites
written and then like a special circumstance,
whatever,
go fuck yourself.
But the fucking fact is is that if you're not worried that there's tanks in the
street and that there's people that are going with m forest door to door with
flak jackets,
I'm that could pull you out and need you to comply right now and they could do
illegal search and seizure and all that happened because this act happened and
that's not terrifying to you then you're no fucking American doing there again.
It's so crazy.
It's all a mistake,
you know,
and the,
the big issue clearly is why are people so angry and broken that they're willing
to do horrific things?
Not The big issue is not like give these people that are quote unquote the
government ultimate control of your life to protect you from things like that
happening.
That's not the answer.
The answer is figuring out what is
wrong with the mental health of human beings that allows a certain percentage of
them to go postal.
What does it,
how do you make people more resilient?
It is the core because you have to make them do you mean by more resilient?
I don't even think it's an accountability thing.
If your nervous system does stupid shit before he had a chance to notice it
happening,
which is the reason a lot of these people do stuff it,
it's happening on automated pilot.
They develop their whole life doing a bunch of stupid shit and it becomes like
automated it.
They'd go to stupid shit first.
I do self destructive things first because it's programmed in their brain,
it's programmed in before they can think about it.
So you can hold someone accountable for what their nervous system did when they
weren't looking,
which is what happens for a lot of these.
So when you,
when you grow up in a shit environment like that,
by the time you get to a certain age and a lot of respects your program to a
terrible way and it's an incredibly difficult thing to reprogram,
how do you,
and it's actually not that hard.
That's why I'm into these things like neuro feedback and hooking computers up
your head and showing your brain where it's not behaving well.
Your brain as an organ self optimizes.
How's that help you?
If you're a kid and you're living in the hood and your,
your,
your mentality is all fucked up.
You grow up in a really violent environment.
Well,
here's how in a study,
and this was with a group called brain state,
there's two states in the u s that don't have basically publicly owned or
privately owned prisons.
So you have these publicly traded prison companies that run things.
So the two states where they don't have this,
these guys went in and they did a test and they said,
give us 10 hours of neurofeedback on people and see what happens.
90% reduction in recidivism.
So they're taking people who are not only in prison,
but they're trained in prisons,
be criminals.
Most criminals go back to prison.
10 hours of being hooked up to a machine,
letting their brains fixed themselves without even having to do any real
conscious effort there.
Changes everything.
I met another girl from an incredibly wrecked family,
like her whole,
she was,
um,
a first nations person in Canada.
This is like the local equivalent of American Indians,
alcoholics in the family,
like you know,
relatives with horrible violent deaths in front of her,
like all the things that fuck you up,
one neurofeedback session for seven days.
She becomes Valedictorian at our school,
stops drinking and completely cleaned herself up so you can get in at the
nervous system level underneath the conscious thing and you can undo an enormous
amount of damage and you can build people that are resilient.
So even when bad stuff happens,
they don't turn into murdering psychos.
We've got to start doing this stuff for people because we're putting stresses on
people that
never,
ever meant to take.
My point is though,
is that sociologically,
the reason I say accountability is because it's like I want the Tsa to take care
of me if I'm on a plane,
therefore I don't have to stand up.
If somebody is coming with a razor blade down the aisle way,
you know what I mean?
All that kind of work that I need.
I need the police to take care of me.
And it's like the more government interest has in us in that way.
The more we're like,
well that's somebody else's providence so we never dust off and get up and stand
up for anybody,
let each other or ourselves,
what kind of ability has to come from it.
That's what I mean,
like having someone else hold you accountable is a worse mood.
Right,
right,
right.
But I mean it's like there's,
I've got to take care of me and I've got to take care of it.
It's like my friend,
a dear friend that I looked up to and he got schizophrenia later in life and his
mom is a woman that helped raise me and I,
I've been wanting to go and,
and uh,
and just thank her and kind of revere her for me being the man I am and her
influence in my life.
And she's dying of cancer and she's in her,
you know,
she's in like a third stage chemotherapy.
And then two weeks ago on top of all of that,
this,
this guy that I'd always looked up to and kind of revered who can't,
who's got mental problems,
man,
he lit himself on fire and um,
and burned off 85% of his skin was,
stayed alive for three days afterwards before they pulled the plug.
And,
uh,
and,
and with,
with all that,
it's like,
you look at who,
who are we taking care of now?
He's got four kids,
you know,
and like,
I feel,
I don't,
I know his oldest boy,
but like,
I feel tremendous responsibility to that community as somebody that I've loved
and grown up with in that like,
you know,
and,
and so giving to a fund for them,
and I'll give every,
every bit I can,
whenever I can,
but it's like,
where do I have responsibility for my community instead of going,
where's my government to take care of him?
You know what I mean?
It's like all those kinds of things.
It's like we need to take care of each other in that way.
And that's what I mean.
I guess when I say a heightened response,
yeah,
you're my community.
You're accountable for what happens around you instead of some random entity
that's going to help you,
certainly kind of a for yourself.
The problem is if you grow up in that terrible environment with a Bot once a
really negative influences and you were programmed in a horrible way,
it's super hard to fucking snap out of that were hard to get your momentum.
It's nearly impossible to do it and see,
just give up.
I had my,
and go,
whatever,
fucking let the system take me and surround yourself with a bunch of other
losers.
I'll rob this one last bank and we'll see.
And either they'll get me or I'll be okay and what,
or whatever the thing is.
You know,
I mean,
you get helpless.
It's like my mom would always talk about,
oh,
the Islamics,
uh,
crazy people that are going to fucking run anybody that'll strap a bomb to
themselves.
I'm like,
I just see that as a frustrated dude.
Like,
that's not insane.
I mean that's,
that's a sociologically induced insanity then in that,
that's somebody that feels so powerless that they'll do that.
Like most of those guys with bombs also like their wife has a gun to their head.
It's a bit of a problem there too.
It's a hard knock life.
I was Mike Tyson,
you got to hang out with Mike Tyson.
Did you talk to him for a bit or anything?
Yeah,
it was pretty bad ass because he's been doing comedy at the comedy.
No Way.
He's amazing when stand up.
Yeah.
Like the last two nights or something.
That's interesting.
Well,
we're going tonight bro.
He does his show.
Um,
he's got a show like where he,
he like does a story and talks about his whole life.
Damn.
Apparently it's fucking amazing.
I got to meet sugar ray Leonard and he was amazing to talk to.
Yeah.
Same kind of like that kind of like those,
that kind of fame as
an athlete,
as a singular athlete.
Like you're not,
you're not a ballplayer or something,
but,
but guys like that,
those are uncommon dudes.
Like,
that's a whole,
that's the life of a rock star.
Like I'm buying out the top two floors of the MGM grand and,
and people that don't even know our stain,
like that's,
those are hundred million dollar fights.
Shit like that.
That's crazy.
So let me bring up some coffee stuff because people in my message,
they want to have this addressed.
Um,
one of them says both
studies found an incidence rate of approximately 50% for the,
Oh,
it please stop that for the incident for the approximately 50% for the Oh,
a producing mold at wildly different concentrations,
minimum of Otu Ppb in one study and a maximum of 7.8 ppb in another.
This tells me anything.
If this tells me anything at all,
it's that you should probably vary your source if you want to minimize your
risk.
And either the FDA or the FSA actually has a legal limit for OAA,
but the e f s a,
whenever the fuck these things are,
suggests a limit of eight.
It looks like a u eight Ugi k g,
which means that even the worst samples are below the very conservative legal
limit.
So you would have to judge,
study one study actually tested the incidents of Oaa and brewed coffee,
not just the beans,
and found a maximum of 7.8 ppb in the brew.
That seven point a Ugi per one kilogram for ground coffee based on the worst
contamination of brewed coffee,
7.8 doing the math,
you'd have to consume the brew from 150 grams of ground coffee per day.
That's about a half of a standard size 10 of coffee per day if he says if you
drink that much.
Same on you.
And the third study,
uh,
looked at Alf,
Alf,
aflatoxin,
what?
Toxic,
not ORC toxin,
a toxin [inaudible] toxin,
which actually is regulated by the FDA and has a maximum of 20 ppb.
This study also showed that approximately 50% incident rate after roasting with
the highest concentration of ATP being 16 kg for Decaf less with caffeine.
So that means with any random cup of coffee,
you have up to a 50% chance of consuming and amount of 80 that's still well
below the FDA limit and that's nearly zero.
Risk says none of the studies test the rate of the mold growth on beans while
storage and the various conditions,
temperature,
humidity,
et cetera.
So we can't comment on what happens in storage.
I guess if you really want to be on the safe side,
only buy as much coffee as you think you can can can use in a week or two.
Conclusion,
it says don't believe this is just what it says.
Don't believe everything that people tell you,
especially people with something to sell.
Unless you're drinking gallons of coffee a day,
gallons of coffee a day brewed coffee is perfectly safe.
No,
the the,
do I sell something?
Yeah,
I saw something that's not even important.
I I get tired of people saying that.
Yeah,
I saw stuff.
Can I say something
on the science of it?
Is that all I know is like from anything,
whether it's a paleo diet or primal diet,
the zone diet or whatever.
It's only because I've read that
and if I've only read it,
I all I have is his talking points,
but I,
I've been my own,
I've been my own experiment with all these things and,
and what I do notice in one of the most telling things when I got bulletproof
coffee is that when you asked me do you sometimes feel or you didn't ask,
okay,
hold on,
stop,
stop.
No disrespect bro.
But I just put out some numbers.
I want them while they're fresh in his mind,
you got to respond to,
it's totally fine.
I mean you were talking about it from an anecdotal standpoint,
which is I know that it helped you and until I enjoyed bulletproof coffee,
but we got to answer this.
So what he's talking about during stored storage of coffee and he was a little
confused because it's storage of green coffee where problems might happen and
controlled humidity levels and green coffee matter enormously.
That's why for instance,
Indonesian coffee,
which tastes really good,
has problems because it's stored with higher humidity.
They even age it there.
So stuff does happen in green coffee.
But what's happening is actually happening during the process that turns it into
green coffee.
There's another set of toxins that come during the transport of coffee,
which is why how the coffee is bagged on.
It's a big container.
Ships actually affects what comes out of the roaster at the other end.
Now this guy is relying on the FDA to tell him the safe amount of aflatoxin to
take.
Now that's a decision he may choose to make.
Frankly,
I don't really trust the FDA to keep my best interests at heart.
The FDA has also basically judging economics and safety.
This is the same FDA that tells you that a spartan is perfectly safe and healthy
for you,
which is complete bullshit.
So okay,
now the point is if it's,
it's somehow it's binary.
If you have this level,
it's unsafe.
it's perfectly safe.
That is not how biology works.
So if your coffee has a level down here versus level down here,
what's the difference?
The difference is human performance and how you feel and how do I measure that?
Well,
we looked at a computerized cognitive battery and had people do a wash out and
we had 54 people in this study and they tried my coffee,
which has zero detectable mycotoxins and other coffee,
which has under the safe limit and okay,
what happened?
Well,
we had better cognitive performance when they had coffee that had fewer toxins
in it.
The idea that it's somehow safe to have this level,
but not this level is not correct having a bachelor.
But this is just stating by your tasks that it's not correct because it is
correct that some substances you can take a little bit of it and be fine and
take a large dose of it and be dead.
That's wandering like salt,
salt,
water or salt.
And you're a dead man and salts.
Important.
Right.
So the question is what's the effect of aflatoxins and Okra toxin on humans?
And I'm sorry,
but I just want to be clear.
So what you're saying is that even a small amount,
although your body may be able to handle it,
your body's processing it,
it's still impedes performance.
Absolutely.
FDA is not addressing it.
They don't look at performance at all.
Like,
like basically is it going to kill you above a certain risk level that they deem
tolerable.
So they get it to a certain point they say,
okay,
other than this you might be getting poisoned.
But if you just drank really shitty coffee,
don't drink
a half a tin of it in a day you're going to be okay.
And you're saying that's not true.
It's not true.
What you're going to feel is you're going to feel anxiety.
And I get lots of people who just gave up coffee like I did because they felt
crappy when they drink it.
Who can drink perfectly clean coffee because different people have different
sensitivities.
And the other thing that this guy hasn't talked about with this numbers,
and this is well established and toxicology,
is that there's a synergism between mycotoxins.
So if you're getting x amount of aflatoxin,
x amount of Okra toxin,
x amount of his Uralla known all together,
that they have a synergistic effect greater than the level of each one of them.
So I test for all those in my,
in my beans and there's zero detectable any of them and that's because of the
process that I engineered to create.
The beans themselves doesn't allow for their formation.
So places where they follow these other companies that are selling.
Michael talks like I saw one website that actually praised your idea for
bulletproof coffee,
which is your own invention based on what does it t that you drank with butters,
Tibetan yak butter tea,
but adding the upgraded MCT too,
it makes a huge difference and that's about mitochondrial function.
There really is a difference in the way it makes you feel.
And you've even said that there's other single source coffee that you can give
this micro toxin free,
clean,
go get it,
go get it.
If you think that bulletproof coffee is expensive,
so does that explain why bulletproof coffee is expensive?
It's like it's a difficult process.
It's your own process.
It's if you buy the five pound bag,
it's the same price as Starbucks coffee.
It's 15 bucks a pound.
Like it's not more expensive.
I don't understand where this is coming from.
If you're buying the small bags,
there's shipping involved and I don't know what to do to make shipping Laura,
but I lose money on shipping on that stuff.
I'm not gouging people on the coffee.
And in fact,
it's very fairly priced given to us.
It doesn't matter.
This is the Internet no matter what.
If the Internet,
if you're making money,
you're ripping somebody off.
Yeah,
it has to be that there's no way I have a day job.
But you've thought about abandoning it and going forward.
Bulletproof life,
to be perfectly honest,
I just switched over to being a contractor in my day job,
literally like last week.
Oh,
so you might eventually go 100% I'm sure.
Hoping to.
But I mean there's a quarter million words I wrote that are free online.
That's it.
That's really important.
That's,
people need to really realize that.
And also there's a lot of time involved in pursuing this much information and
people,
for whatever reason,
was just going to expert on everything.
That's like what's been said in my,
okay,
but,
but it's what it is,
is you're an expert on all these things that you've spent time researching and
you've accumulated a bunch of information on and look,
there's,
there's something important about that and people need to get that in your head.
You're not going to do that.
But he's going to do that and that is important.
But even if you making a dollar off it,
people just want to thank that somehow.
Another,
you're a fucking con artist.
It's really interesting because bottom line is if you want to drink some coffee,
that idea is the best idea.
The bulletproof coffee idea is the best idea and it tastes like when,
when you have the grass fed butter in it and you put a little Stevia take,
turn me on.
It's a little Stevia.
Damn,
it's fucking delicious.
And it will give you a different kind of energy over a long period of title if
you'd like to have coffee.
But if you'd like to operate at a higher level,
it's like,
it's like even if you don't,
if vegetarianism made me feel awesome,
great,
I'd be a vegetarian,
I would do whatever I would do whatever it was.
[inaudible] woman said it's like Adderall.
Like this shit is like Adderall.
Yeah.
Um,
but,
but what is the,
there's what is the downside?
Is there any downside for drinking this stuff?
I mean,
and getting all jacked up.
it doesn't have play havoc on your adrenals.
I mean,
that's a really good question.
Let's talk about adrenal function and a lot.
Yeah.
All right.
Caffeine depletes magnesium to a small degree.
Not a terrible one,
but you should be supplementing magnesium.
Anyway,
it's my top two supplement recommendations or vitamin D and magnesium.
That's by the way interrupt.
But that's one of the reasons why she used the tank.
The isolation tanks.
One of the best ways that your body gets magnesium and it gets absorbed through
the dermis.
Bitch.
Yeah,
that's an Epsom salt bath.
Yeah.
Taking,
just not a warm,
warm salt dehydrates,
but Luke warm,
so it's so extended me.
That's great.
For the muscle
at some magnesium chloride,
not just magnesium sulfate to that.
And you'll get even more benefits.
What am I getting is in the Zma zinc
and is that enough?
Probably not.
Oral magnesium is,
it will get you to a certain point,
but transdermal is amazing.
So what should I throw in there which are throwing it right now you have
sulfate,
magnesium sulfate,
you want to put magnesium chloride,
which is actually like the salt of magnesium because that absorbs through the
skin differently.
You see that magnesium oil,
they mark it like at health food stores.
That's just super saturated magnesium chloride.
So adds some of that.
But let's go back to adrenals.
Um,
I'll,
I'll hook you up with him.
That magnesium chloride,
just the chemical stuff.
You can buy pounds of this stuff and just put some of that in there too.
So when you're getting your magnesium,
you'll get sulfate and chloride in both channels.
We'll get in.
So with adrenals,
I know that mycotoxins increased cortisol levels,
they are a poison.
When you are poisoned,
your stress levels go up,
which stresses your adrenal glands.
This is like pretty basic stuff.
So maybe higher doses of mycotoxins create more adrenal stress,
lower doses,
create less.
So having coffee without toxins in it.
If you have adrenal problems,
it seems to be okay.
I have lots and lots of people on the forums who are in up to stage three
adrenal fatigue who have one cup of upgraded beans,
you know the,
the micro toxin free coffee and they do very well.
They recover.
I've been in Stage three adrenal fatigue multiple times and I still use a cup of
coffee.
I've tried going without coffee.
I've tried going with it.
And the bottom line is if you're doing it responsibly,
I think doing it with the fat,
which actually lowers your stress level when your body has adequate food and
adequate nutrition like that I think is at least a wash and it's probably not
harmful.
But if you have adrenal fatigue,
like real,
like I'm bedridden sorta stuff you probably,
I'm not to be using anything with caffeine.
The funny thing you say is like maybe the mycotoxins are causing this adrenal
response.
Like that needs to be sort of research,
right?
Well,
I would love more research out there.
Would we know that like aflatoxin and Okra toxin if they're injected or if you
feed them to an animal that they will raise quarters.
All that.
That's very well understood.
Would be a way that you could do a test on coffee and to find out with,
you know,
x amount of Pete,
but what sort of a control would you need to do a test on people and ensure that
they get a certain amount of mycotoxins in the coffee and then ensure that they
get none.
It seems like that to be done,
you could certainly ensure it.
I'd be actually really interested in that.
I,
I would contribute coffee to a study like that,
although I don't know where to get aflatoxin guaranteed certified level coffee.
One of the problems that we have with coffees,
if you buy a container load of coffee,
there can be a hotspot.
The back of the container had a leak and so now you get like this,
much of the container has mycotoxins in it and the rest doesn't.
And this is one of the reasons that the small style roasting that I'm doing
works.
If you go up to like the massive coffee conglomerate level where you're mixing
like a whole bunch of container lives together and you're homogenizing it,
you're getting the average level down,
but you're guaranteeing the presence of toxins.
I want zero toxins,
not just,
Oh,
just a little bit.
Essentially what's going on as these toxins are not really being considered as
toxins because no one's dying and even though they suck for your health and they
make you feel like shit,
no one's paying attention to it and the valley doesn't address it,
and the way they're looking at as far as regulation is a profit versus negative
detriment to the human health,
which is seems to be very low.
[inaudible]
used to be,
although it makes you feel kind of cranky,
it's not really detrimental to your health.
Is that doing research on mycotoxins and arterial lesions do a search on
mycotoxins and fertility.
There's a whole chapter in this book on what Mycotoxins do to animals.
We actually test to animal feed before when animals are pregnant,
they buy special food without mycotoxins in it because when they feed toxin
grain and hay and Alfalfa to animals,
they spontaneously lose their pregnancies and they can't get pregnant.
Like we know what these do to animals.
But for those same things,
we don't even have let set for humans.
For some of you,
well this is what I think we really need to do to continue this conversation and
sort of an ethical way.
Cause I think we're bringing up a lot of things that we can't really completely
substantiate.
Like the mycotoxin levels and different coffees like Starbucks and Peet's and
whatever shit at the mall and the gas station.
I feel like there needs to be some sort of study done or some tests done on a
bunch of different different ones.
Just randomly pull them out of Starbucks and test him.
How difficult would that be and could you do that and why haven't you done it
yet?
Well,
I mean,
I would in order to do that,
I mean just testing is not cheap.
It's not cheap.
And why would it cost to do that when you want like a thousand samples?
How many samples would we need?
Tape?
I mean like,
I know,
but I'll be the Guinea pig.
I'll do whatever it takes it out.
We're going to have butter in this coffee or what?
I would say 50 samples when they need state.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a good call.
Yeah,
but you don't want to go to Hawaii.
That's a lot of work out minus and lower 48 and here's the question.
I mean,
are you going to test like
Folgers?
You're going to test it,
you know,
just Starbucks.
Starbucks,
I think you'd want to test Dunkin donuts.
You don't want to test.
You should do five,
right?
I think we'd get a good sample is if you randomly tested,
you know,
50 places in this country just went into a place and bought a coffee and then
wrote the day,
the time where it came from,
whether it was coffee bean,
whether it was Pete's,
whatever it is,
whatever mom and pop coffee shop and let's find out.
Just just,
I mean that's obviously not good enough scientifically to prove across the
board,
but it's a sample enough to give people some information.
It'll,
it's a sample enough to,
we were talking to $100,000 like a hundred grand.
I'm not feel like we could do a Kickstarter that
I'm not going to put that shit out Starbucks and ask him like,
Hey,
do you want to hit this out of the water out of the way?
I don't think they know their business.
They know frame that they want to do that.
Working as managers,
do you think they know,
I've talked to like some of the most prestigious coffee scientists in the world
working for like five plus billion dollar companies about this problem.
They damn well know about that
as their baristas racist.
Don't know.
But let's say working in the store,
it's about a Barista.
What about a manager that used to be a Barista?
They fell a man.
Not at all.
Like like poison.
There's a company,
if you want to look crazy,
they'll go in there and ask,
Hey,
do you have single origin coffee at a Starbucks
or what?
So what?
What's going on here?
This is a,
a backend industrial supply issue with coffee.
So there's one of the very large coffee conglomerates has a giant research
facility with Sephora,
with 70 scientists working on this now.
And in Europe they've had to change the way they buy green coffee because now
they make the people who buy the green coffee from the coffee growers.
So there's a growing production process.
There's a coffee,
a broker and the coffee broker buys it.
But if they don't arrange for proper transportation in the coffee can actually
develop mycotoxins in transportation.
So what's happening now is that the roasters in the supply chain there are
actually forcing the brokers would,
who never had to be responsible to this before in Europe.
They're forcing the brokers to take on that risk and it's changing a lot of the
whole part of coffee over there.
But we haven't had that happen here.
On top of that,
according to the last research I've seen,
Starbucks has $816 million worth of coffee in storage that they're working on.
So now if we're going to do a sample of $860 million worth of coffee just for
Starbucks,
and I'm not picking on Starbucks,
there's lots of giant coffee companies who buy all kinds of coffees.
Some is moldy psalms not moldy.
They mix it all together.
So like which samples are we going to get?
And if we ask them for samples,
I wonder if we'll get the freshest,
nicest stuff or not.
Like who knows?
So if it sits around,
it's more likely to have mycotoxins.
It's around as green coffee that is not in a temperature controlled environment.
Yeah,
definitely humidity and temperature matter.
When you're storing coffee.
So if it's,
and depending also like if it's African natural coffee,
that stuff always has mold in it just because of the way it's processed.
So I mean,
well,
okay.
It's um,
I don't even want to say it's unlikely or likely that they're going to have
African coffee.
I don't know what Starbucks coffee for sure.
Yeah,
they do.
I've seen it a bunch of times,
but that's like the stuff they're advertising is like,
you know,
special Zimbabwe,
summarize that for you.
You know,
figure southern Africa is bad for you.
Some Ethiopian coffee and tell your parents someone super clean.
Nice.
So here's,
here's the deal.
Um,
yeah,
you can get a clean cup of coffee at a high end.
Coffee House was single origin following the instructions on my website.
I don't make a nickel from that.
My dream is to be able to go to any coffee place on the planet,
walk in the door and say,
I want a cup of coffee.
That makes me feel good.
And it doesn't happen along those lines,
like I'm working on opening bulletproof coffee shops.
Like it's,
it's happening.
It'll happen.
Like probably this year.
I'm bringing the team together.
We're raising funding for them.
Yeah,
like bulletproof team bullet Covo groups.
You know,
it's called the mumble through.
Bobby has bulletproof Ted.
We're going to call it the Rogan team now.
Where are you going to start?
Where's the first place?
San Francisco.
We're going to put three coffee shops in San Francisco.
Wow,
nice.
And,
and I'm doing this not to make $1 million cause trust me people,
if you want to make $1 million opening retail establishments sucks.
It is.
I don't even know how to do this.
I had to bring people in.
You could tell me how to do this stuff and I haven't raised a nickel yet,
but it will happen and it's,
it's just hard.
You know,
every paper Cup does something to the margins and it's,
it's actually something I have no experience in,
but I'm doing it because I think that you should be able to buy a bulletproof
coffee and feel awesome.
I want to give you a little bit of vindication because someone else on the board
of dude named Equiv found some studies that found 52% to 91% of green coffee
beans are contaminated with mycotoxins.
Yep.
And,
and this is from NB and CBI.
I know that study,
national coffee brewers board something,
I forget what it is,
but there are studies that show 92% government study.
It's by nih.gov there we go.
That's not the one,
I forget what the fuck it is.
I have like 10 studies like that on the site and depending on where the coffee
comes from,
what year it is,
whether there was a drought and all that,
it affects it.
Even national center for bio informing bio technology information.
Okay.
Advanced Science and help by providing access to biomedical and Doe Genomic
Information.
Sorry.
So here's the thing.
There are plenty of studies.
There are lots of studies out there that say there are some,
there are those things.
Look,
like I said,
that guy cited that say that,
you know,
it's all bs,
I wish it was all bs.
I really do.
This is the biggest one.
They found 60 samples in Brazil.
91% I sat the 1.7 contaminated with molds.
Wow.
That's kind of scary because if that coffee is mixed in with your other coffee,
what are you getting?
And you could make the argument you're getting a safe level.
You know what?
Screw the safe level.
I'm not interested in the safe level.
I wanted an optimal level.
I'm not mediocre.
Would really like to be able to prove this.
I would really like if there was a way that we could absolutely prove that these
have
some sort of a detrimental effect because I,
there's,
there's makes sense to me.
I believe what you're saying in studies,
I know from trying your coffee,
your car,
I have no adverse effects and I have had headaches from coffee before.
Weird feelings afterwards.
I feel like shit and I've always wondered what that was and I think a lot of
people may have those sort of same shitty feelings after a cup of coffee and
they just accept it.
Yup.
Right.
There's so many different things.
You got to talk to Obama about that president of Starbucks,
I think he'd be open to having a public conversation about,
you know,
that'd be fascinating.
I think you what?
Starbucks is a pretty good company,
like good people company for Howard Schultz and I have huge respect for
[inaudible].
He knows name.
Oh well I know that someone told him about MCT oil last week.
I told him about it.
Yeah.
In what way?
Well,
some of the people that I'm working with on my coffee shops are original
gangsters,
Starbucks people,
original gangster.
They learned how to brew with him and then they're like,
you know what,
this is not good enough.
All the Starbucks has been around since like the 80s.
Right.
So they just,
they had their career and they're done,
but they're looking to do something new and interesting.
I'll tell you what,
even if it's bad for you,
it's fucking delicious.
I can't,
and I don't think,
I don't think it's bad for you.
Um,
click,
Tate had one more question and we should address before we wrap this picture
off.
And that was,
you had a question about cholesterol and I think that's important.
We never really got to the bottom of that.
What,
what's the issue and what should be worried about?
Like how dare you put that down,
right?
It's going to get us in trouble.
That's gonna get us in trouble.
Um,
the,
that would be a way better logo on their
cholesterol.
Alright.
Cholesterol.
If you don't have oxidized cholesterol and you don't have inflammation in your
body,
having cholesterol is not a risk factor.
The way we've been taught it is even having LDL cholesterol isn't higher levels
of Ldl let you build muscle.
Like that's just sort of not,
I haven't worked out in three years.
Wow.
40 minutes a month.
Here's another thing.
People who have high levels of unoxidized cholesterol,
when they're exposed to poisons,
they live a lot longer because your body uses cholesterol to escort toxins out
of the body through the biliary system in the liver.
So why have we been told that cholesterol is bad for you?
Is it cholesterol on a diet with other things?
Cholesterol was one of the first things we could measure in blood.
So we've been focusing a lot of research on it since about what the 30s but the
Gary Tobbs type of people as well as it's a huge body of research in the last
couple of years have come out really seriously questioning this.
If you have adequate amounts of high density cholesterol,
the HDL,
which you do if you eat this kind of old proof diet stuff.
I'm sorry,
I don't know what else to call it.
That's okay.
I'm just doing your that slide.
So I caught him and named my book that I have to change it.
So there's that.
What you'll end up doing,
by the way,
your cholesterol is about 300 on this?
Yeah,
mine's about to 47 okay.
And my LPP,
La two which is the one I'd worry about the most,
is very low and I don't have that number memorized.
Lpp two is a measure
of protein damage inside your arteries if you don't have ILP PLA.
Two,
if your homocysteine is low,
which is a marker of inflammation.
So of course it is.
It takes six weeks on the side where people to just crater it out,
right?
And then your c reactive protein and homocysteine are the other big markers of
inflammation.
So you get those guys where they should be and having cholesterol that isn't
oxidized is actually good for you.
If you're taking your eggs and you're making like well-cooked omelettes out of
them and you're cooking the yolks to death,
you're oxidizing that cholesterol and that's inflammatory at the end of the day.
Or you should be eating raw eggs,
egg yolks,
absolutely toss them in your smoothie.
There are amazing.
It makes it taste like ice cream.
Don't have to worry about Salmonella wash the outside of the egg.
One in 45,000 eggs have salmonella on.
It's on the outside of the egg,
so any outside of the egg.
So when you crack it open,
that's when you get it in the actual egg itself.
So it's a dirty egg and that's something that people don't ever do that never
wash the outside of it.
Right?
They come,
Washington,
the u s anyway,
some under motivated fuck the Illuminati hose and the Illuminati working
together.
This is the guy that could eat me.
Me Out credit GSA.
Listen man,
I need to do a podcast with both you motherfuckers individually again cause I'm
already even scratched the surface.
Let's do it individually and together,
which is so nice.
We're going to do one together.
I think tomorrow take you got your own podcast.
Now how do people get that state bulletproof.com or not of a bit on,
uh,
for the,
for my attorney,
you guys working together or not yet?
Maybe tomorrow we'll find on it and in bulletproof is a common mark so nobody
can,
it's yours.
Nobody can steal it.
That's still around for a long ass time for you to come along and jacket.
That doesn't even make sense.
You know,
bulletproof ideas had been around since the beginning of time,
but if you're going to do bulletproof coffee,
are you going to do it around food products?
You're going to do it around me.
I'm going to ask some questions.
That's all I'm going to say.
You shouldn't be able to own the term bulletproof.
They can own your genes.
Joe Tate Fletcher,
I'm generous.
Talk to me if you want to use it,
but you can't just say,
I'm going to make,
we can do,
let's get it on proof potato.
Suppose not exist.
It's too late.
Yeah,
it's over.
One more time.
How do people get it?
A state bulletproof.com or you can go to take Q fletcher.com and find out all
about stuff like that.
Then Dave Asprey,
you can get him on Twitter.
It's bulletproof Exec,
uh,
at bulletproof exec on Twitter.
And your website is the bulletproof executive.
Bulletproof bulletproof exact dot.
Call it proof exact.com and you have hundreds of thousands of bits of
information on there for people to get.
That's absolutely free for anybody who thinks you just trying to sell shit.
And by the way,
it need to be noted that he had that website up.
We was selling nothing for years.
Just wanting to put information out there that,
you know,
don't be mad at that.
And I want to thank a couple of my sponsors that are also those guys that are
just,
here's something that they did and that's original nutritionals,
uh,
dot com uh,
virus,
international deuce gym and work out of the day to go see Douche Jim,
deuce Deuce,
terrible,
terrible name for a gym.
Awesome.
Excellent.
Excellent from the Shit Jim.
Otherwise no one has to do you know what you do and I already have words in my
mouth.
Dig Party in my mouth.
Dot Com.
Go there for details.
That's a real site.
Um,
gave afrobeat spice.
Thank you very much.
It really,
really fascinating.
We've got to do this again man.
I'm sure we the the message board by the way,
a skeptical as you Fox may be.
I love you guys and uh,
I appreciate your curiosity and even though I think some of it is a little bit
unfounded,
I appreciate your skeptical nature and uh,
your,
your ability to question things and I do too.
Excellent ways.
Ask the questions.
Yeah.
If they met you,
they'd love you.
All right,
thanks everybody.
Thanks.
Thanks to stamp.com code word j r e.
Go there,
get some,
go to rogan.ting.com save 25 bucks.
And last but not least on it,
used the code name Rogan at o,
n n I.
T and save yourself 10% off.
Okay,
we'll be back tomorrow with Eddie [inaudible] cause we love the fuck out of that
dude.
All right,
take care.
You guys.